Yes.
Is it good?
Yeah,
go ahead.
All right.
Cut all this sounds right.
Right,
right.
Hello Adam.
Hey,
thanks for having me.
Thanks for being here,
man.
I'm pretty sure I'm a giant fan of your show.
I really appreciate the fact that it annoys people to really business people
off.
That's the goal,
pretty much,
you know,
I mean,
I'm not a cat person where I'm like,
ah,
if you're pissing people off,
you're doing something right.
But there's some tricks to this to that.
And also the way you structured the name,
I mean,
I don't know if you came up with the name of it,
but Adam ruins everything.
I think I might have to give that to my,
to my former boss,
Sam writes to college humor.
Might've might've,
uh,
I think we came up with the name together.
He might've been the first person to say it,
but uh,
yeah.
Thank you.
I'm really,
I,
yeah,
like let's,
you know,
it lets you know that,
hey,
this is going to know you a little bit,
but like,
I'm going to be telling you shit that you don't want to hear.
That's gonna make everything a little bit worse,
you know?
But at the end of the day,
it makes it better.
It's an optimistic show at the end of the day where,
sure,
yeah.
Yeah.
You give them the truth.
I think that,
yeah,
I mean the,
the,
the thesis of the show is that it's always better to know the truth and it's a
momentarily uncomfortable,
but hopefully for most people,
99% of people who watch the show,
it grinds your gears a little bit to find out something,
oh,
I thought that was true with the act crap,
you know?
But then at the end,
we show you why you're actually better off knowing that thing and you're always
better off knowing the truth in my view,
in my view as well.
Yeah.
Was there ever,
was there one episode that stands out as being one that people got the most
upset about a year?
There's a bunch of them.
I mean,
people get,
people get upset with us for a lot of different reasons.
We did one about how I'm a breastfeeding isn't better than formula feeding.
It's a no,
they're both like formula feeding is fine,
you know,
and if the problem is if eating become a stigma to stigmatized now,
um,
and there's a lot of people who can't breastfeed or who for medical reasons,
you know,
uh,
and uh,
the fact is that forming formula is like a scientifically proven wonderful way
to feed a baby.
And if you know someone's choice or need us to do that,
there's no reason to stigmatize.
And we go through all the reasons that,
that that's the case.
And yeah,
people get a little,
you know,
there's a lot of people who sort of have an ideology about that,
and uh,
don't want to hear the truth about it.
Um,
we did one about a trophy hunting animals about how cause people,
young people get so mad.
I'll look at this guy shot a lion,
right?
And the truth is that,
uh,
in some countries,
not 100% of the time,
but in some countries,
they are effectively using trophy hunting as a way to,
to,
uh,
protect the animals because that's how they're able to sort of like monetize,
you know,
in that place.
And,
uh,
you know,
get money coming in,
in order to protect the animals.
And they're,
they're very specific and strategic about it and it can be part of a good,
you know,
sort of animal management,
strategy and it's being used to some success,
you know?
Um,
and yeah,
people don't want to hear that.
Right.
It's still really hard.
That's a weird one to me.
And I hunt.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that the whole,
the whole lion and elephant
thing,
right?
Ooh,
that's a weird one.
But know what they can do is they can say,
okay,
well we've got these elephants,
one of these elephants is an old male that's like killing the other elephants.
Right.
And if we organize these hunts where you got to pay half a million dollars for
the right to even go in there,
right.
Well with the old male elephants.
I know that was the issue with that giraffe.
That woman that got actually don't know that specific case.
Yeah,
there was a,
there was a woman who got in trouble because she shot this really beautiful
giraffe.
It was really dark and unusually colored and it was dark because it was very
old.
The older the Giraffe,
apparently the males get really dark.
It was really cool looking.
Um,
but she shot it and everybody went crazy on the internet because,
you know,
she was posing and smiling with this drought.
But apparently that giraffe had to be killed because it had killed at least two,
maybe three young males,
and it was no longer have a viable breeding age.
So they were in this situation where they didn't have the money to take it and
bring it to a zoo somewhere and the,
they would have gotten money from having this woman come in and shoot it.
So that's what they did.
Yeah,
that's Sorta,
that's sort of the idea,
you know.
Um,
I mean,
one of the issues is if you've got an area where,
you know,
one of the problems is you need to have a reason for the people who live in the
place to care about the animals.
You know what I mean?
If it's just like,
hey,
the elephants are going to roam free,
well you've got people there who are like,
all right,
fine.
So I'm living near some elephants.
Occasionally they eat my crops and shit and that annoys me.
I don't really give occasionally.
Yeah,
exactly.
I don't give a shit about that.
And what that allows to happen is allows poachers to come in and kill them.
Wantonly Right?
But if instead,
okay,
we're protecting them,
we have a revenue stream,
right?
We get money when,
you know,
hunters come in and pay a lot of money to go kill one animal.
Right now we've got a way to hire guards.
We've got a way this is now a resource that we're protecting.
Right?
And that sounds a little cynical,
but it is working in some places and it's both.
It's cynical and effect and effective.
And we have a,
we had a woman on from the IECN International Union for Conservation of nature,
big conservation group,
talking about how this is effective now in some places,
if you've got a corrupt government where they're just going to pocket the bunny.
Yeah,
that's bad.
Right?
But the point is just because the mere idea of someone going overseas and
killing an animal is not necessarily the worst thing in the world.
We have to look at the details of the situation.
And it's hard for animal lovers to hear.
Animal lovers don't like to hear that.
Uh,
yeah,
they don't.
They don't.
And I,
like I said,
I don't like to hear it.
You hear it either.
I wish people would just,
it just what freaks me out more than anything is that there's no other options.
It's not like a bunch of people are donating a bunch of money to keep these
areas clean and free of poachers.
And
the amount would be massive.
Right?
We can,
we can donate money,
but yeah,
that,
that's the,
when you've got a problem that big and intractable as how do you save these
animals,
you know,
and uh,
against habitat encroachment,
right?
Again,
you know,
people want to farm on that land.
People,
you know,
people have,
people have lives,
right?
They're not sitting around going,
the people in those countries not sitting around going,
oh,
I love the cute elephants.
Like we have the luxury to do.
They like fucking live there.
Right?
And so how do you get,
how do you get those people and that society to,
to really protect those animals?
That's a hard question to answer.
And some places are having success with that strategy and that's something that
we can understand.
We don't have to approve of it in every single case.
And we can say that's really tough for us as animal lovers.
And in fact,
the character I'm talking to on the show says,
I still just hate the idea of an animal being killed,
right?
And I said,
yes.
So Do I.
Right.
We try to dramatize that emotional,
you know,
resistance on the show,
like that emotional reaction that we have.
I also don't like the idea of,
of an animal being killed brutally.
You know,
I think I'm uncomfortable with the idea,
right?
But if my main goal is to preserve the population of these animals overall and
stopped them from going extinct,
maybe I need to accept that this tough truth that once in a time,
once in a while,
once gotta be shot through the head with a rifle,
maybe I need to accept that it's,
it's weird.
That's what I chose about really when it comes to things
we don't eat,
like lions and stuff
and the psychology,
Michael Douglas and the,
what was that movie with the Val Kilmer,
the ghost and the darkness that the lions that decided to kill those dudes are
what never heard of this movie.
Great movie ghost in the darkness.
I feel like it's from the 90s,
but it's a really good movie about a true story about this guy that they
brought.
They brought this Michael Douglas character was brought in to hunt these lions
that were systematically targeting and killing these workers that worked on this
railroad.
This team of lions worked together and started eating people.
Wow,
that's great.
My Way and
it sounds like it.
And they have to,
they have to go for the lions.
They have to go kill these lines.
Yeah,
there it is.
Ghost in the darkness.
Oh holy hell biting tension.
That is a great tell Kilmer's looking good there.
No,
that was pre Fatso Kilmer
pretty when he went off to do it was too good looking guy handle anymore looking
guy too.
Handsome
problem.
You had to just go off the deep end.
Another one people got really mad about this is this weirdly the one we got the
biggest reaction to.
Um,
and to the extent that I'm a little hesitant talking about it,
cause it always starts to shift storm every time I do.
But scenes.
Uh,
no,
actually we've not done a whole one on vaccines.
Uh,
but we really should cause it's coming back.
I used to think that vaccines was like kind of done as a topic and like we've
gone through it.
It is really,
it is really backing.
It is big.
Um,
but no,
we did one on Alpha males.
We had an episode about dating and we did one on how the idea of the Alpha male
doesn't exist in humans.
Like if you talk to any anthropologist,
any biologist and you sociologists,
right?
And be like,
Dee Dee are humans organized in a social relationship where there's Alphas and
Betas?
The be like,
no,
what are you talking about?
This is an unscientific idea.
Right?
And we just did something laying that out in a,
in the,
in the context of like,
people who are all my type is,
I like Alphas,
right?
Well,
there's no such thing actually,
you know,
humans are some,
your dominant,
some situations not in others.
Right?
Um,
it's an overly simplistic way of looking human relationships.
And I thought that was a pretty simple,
straightforward thing.
I was like,
there's just a bit of pseudoscience that you hear people tossing out and people
went ballistic on the Internet because people have sort of like built a edifice
of ideology in their minds about like,
there's Alphas,
they're spayed is I'm an Alpha,
this is what now feels like,
this is what a Beta is like,
you know,
um,
and uh,
words.
Yeah.
They're there.
They're clearly men who are more aggressive and athletic and dominant and more
confident and s and then men who are introverted and shy and more nervous and
anxious.
And there's a scale
in some,
in some situations,
you know,
situations.
Yeah.
And that's what we're talking about,
right?
In social.
Well,
yeah,
but you're a social situation could change based on what situation you're in.
You know what I mean?
Like,
but,
uh,
a login,
athletic,
confident male is always going to be an athletic,
confident male and an introverted anxious male who has problems with social
anxiety is going to be the same.
That's that,
that that's
personally,
I don't think so necessarily.
Um,
but,
uh,
so when we're talking about Alpha,
when you talk about Alphas,
right?
Um,
in animals,
what is that?
It's a social hierarchy,
right?
When you're done,
take away that word.
I mean w but what people are using to describe when they're saying Alphas and
Betas,
they're saying like confident,
strong,
secure people and people that are anxious and not sure.
So if you're,
so if you're trying to say,
hey,
like it's good to be confident and not so great to be anxious like that,
that's fine.
Right?
But when people talk about Alpha males and Beta males right there specifically
bringing in the language of like evolution of biology,
of zoology,
of,
of evolutionary psychology,
you know,
and they'll start saying stuff like,
well,
there's Alphas and there's Betas and women are hardwired to be attracted to the
Alpha,
you know,
because that's what it's like in nature.
Like there'll be using that language.
Right?
And so what we're pointing out is that's not scientific,
right?
It's not scientific.
But it is true that women are hardwired to be attracted to confident athletic
men.
I don't know.
Well,
I don't know if I agree with that.
Um,
but yeah,
you don't think that women look at like pro athletes.
And like big,
strong athletic men.
And you don't think they're drawn to that for evolutionary reasons?
I know.
I don't actually,
I think
that men are drawn to women with small waists and big hips and large breasts for
evolutionary reasons,
reasons,
uh,
you know,
I think that's an easy,
I think what that is,
is that an easy intuition to come to if you're like looking at the way people
behave,
right.
But one of the things about evolutionary psychology is it's the most common
mistake to look at the way that people do behave and say,
the reason what the we behave that way is because evolution says that's the best
way.
Right?
That's their argument.
For instance,
I'll give you an exact,
that's the argument that was arguments like that were used for instance,
to justify slavery,
right?
That like,
oh,
because you know,
uh,
whites and blacks have this hierarchical relationship and American society,
that's the way it was intended.
That's how nature intended it to be.
Right?
But we can't,
we get it
giant loop.
The shapes of bodies.
Men Universally are attracted to a certain shape of bodies.
There's men that are attracted to different ones and do that
at the same area,
but that hourglass shape has been throughout time,
something that men are attracted to.
I think that hourglass shape,
but something throughout our recent cultural memory that we tell each other that
men are attracted to it.
Right?
That's when,
that's when we're,
that's what we're told from an early age to this,
that this is the sort of women that men are attracted to and so a lot of men
ended up adopting that.
Right.
But I don't think that deep down that's how men naturally are.
You know,
I read this or that,
but that doesn't make any sense to me.
That's so intuitive because I'm all about things that are not intuitive,
but where do you think it started?
Where do you think this,
this narrative of men being attracted to women with large breasts in a small
waist and a big ass?
Where do you think that started?
Because this is like evolutionary biology is pretty much settled on the idea
that the reason why the large hips would indicate that the woman be easier to
give birth.
Having large breasts and a large acid indicate that she has,
uh,
she's,
she's fertile and then she has an ample fat storage in the right places if she's
going to be pregnant and carry children.
There's all these like evolutionary biology reasons why people are attracted to
certain things.
Why woman,
we'd be attracted to a tall,
muscular,
handsome man.
Good genetics,
very strong and confident could take care of her.
All these things are based on evolutionary biology.
So in understand why you think these are learned sort of cultural artists.
So my,
my question is,
this is an assumption that we,
the public make about how evolutionary biology works,
right?
It's more of a thing that we sort of agree on.
Well,
we,
we as the,
like there's a,
there's an idea among the public that this is true.
I don't know if it's a scientific idea.
That's my,
I've had conversations with evolutionary biologist who explained the reason why
men are attracted to certain shapes and why women are attracted to certain
shapes.
This is,
this is sort of,
I mean,
this is science in a way.
I mean this,
the reason why they're attracted to tall men that are muscular and confident is
because that is what's always saved you throughout history.
I mean co to only make sense,
doesn't it?
It it.
Well,
just because it makes the point of our show,
right,
is that just because something makes intuitive sense doesn't mean that it's
necessarily true.
Right?
You think that in this case that this is a varied argument,
like I don't think that's something that you can dismiss.
I don't,
I don't dismiss it,
but I don't assume the truth of it simply because that's what you know everybody
agrees upon.
Right?
If you ask girls like,
what are you into?
And you say,
if you are you into tall,
muscular,
confident men who are also nice to do,
Jesus Christ,
it's going to be off the charts.
It's going to be like most of them.
I'm,
you know,
I'm really,
I'm really not sure that's the case.
Really.
Yeah.
You,
you had like a survey of,
and the
men were equally kind and equally intelligent and,
and friendly.
You don't think that more women will be sexually attracted to these tall,
handsome men with great bodies?
I mean,
look,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna say that first of all,
you're positing like a value judgment in it,
that the,
that the bodies are great,
right?
So like are women attracted to attractive bodies?
If that's the question then,
then I would say of course more attracted to women's study finds some fucking
I'm talking about with the dad bod.
Here's something that I was really influenced by.
I ran what I just said though.
That doesn't make sense to you that women would be attracted to someone who's
fit.
Look,
I mean,
it's a,
it's a hypothetical rate.
Like I certainly athleticism,
right?
Is something that is attractive.
Right?
Um,
that's something that many people find attractive,
right?
Not everybody finds that attractive.
Um,
and I don't think that we can necessarily recent backwards to like a specific
evolutionary relationship.
Right?
Um,
because the truth of what those evolutionary relationships are is like often a
lot more complicated then you know,
our,
our immediate intuition about it.
And what were you specifically pushing back against in that segment is like the
really sort of unscientific,
you know,
of Alpha and Beta.
Yeah,
exactly.
Where it's like,
you know,
you've got people,
just on internet forums like sort of doing amateur pseudoscience,
right?
Saying like,
this is how the relationships between men and women are like designed
evolutionarily.
Um,
and we were just pointing out on a very,
very simple level,
like the Alpha and Beta social hierarchy theory,
right?
Um,
that like a humans are organized in a social hierarchy and Alphas are above
Betas.
Not True.
Right?
Um,
even someone who is the person who you posited,
right?
The person who is a athletic and confidence,
The,
uh,
you know,
the high school football quarterback,
right?
Versus the high school football nerd,
right.
We'll take those two people and then put them in a different situation,
If those two people are like in gym class together,
right.
Of course,
the high school quarterback is like,
I'm the top of that social interaction,
right.
I'm looking at the sort of,
you know,
classic Wolf Pack Model.
They're the one who sort of sort of running the show,
right?
And the other guys like hanging out in the bleachers,
talking to his friends,
right?
Or talking to nobody because he's a,
he's a Beta and that situation,
right?
If you then take that kid and then you,
you know,
send that kid to like nationals,
right?
Or whatever,
uh,
you know,
and that kid,
sorry,
I take the quarterback character,
um,
and you know,
he suddenly like,
you know,
from the little podunk town,
right?
He's not from the big school.
Um,
he's like way down on the Totem Pole,
right?
That person is no longer going to be in that high social hierarchy,
Um,
and if you take that nerd and you put that,
you know,
take that kid,
maybe he's the dungeon master of his,
you know,
dungeon and dragons group,
right?
Um,
uh,
that,
why that kid is going to be the alpha in that situation,
right?
That's how humans work.
You know,
humans aren't organized in sort of like little pods that stay together for life,
and there's one person who's dominant the whole time,
right?
And that's the simple point that we were making,
uh,
in that,
right?
Um,
and people got upset.
Yeah,
people got upset because there are so many people who we talked about this later
on the show,
there's this idea called the backfire effect,
right?
Where when people are told something that they don't agree with,
um,
that when they,
when they,
someone has told somebody a fact,
when somebody has told the fact that contradicts like a really deeply held
belief,
it can often cause them to disbelieve it even when it's true.
Right?
In fact,
that fight back even harder,
one of the reasons that happens is because of an idea called identity protective
cognition.
It's,
um,
if the fact that is being debunked is literally part of your identity.
Like if a sign that you believe really,
really deeply,
it's incredibly hard for you to disbelieve it,
right?
The classic example of this is like,
you know,
Sean Hannity,
Sean Hannity doesn't believe in climate change,
right?
Uh,
uh,
really?
Uh,
well,
you know what,
uh,
I actually don't know that specifically what Shawnee,
Sean Handy things about climate change.
And let's just say somebody who's made their whole career on climate change
doesn't exist,
right?
All their friends are in the anti climate change community,
Uh,
they met their wife at an anti climate change fund raiser.
You know what I mean?
They make their money,
they write a new anti climate change book every year.
Right?
Now,
climate change is real,
right?
There's no evidence I could present that person with that is going to make them
take the social risk of ending all their relationships changing their whole
life.
Right.
Uh,
because if they were to say,
okay,
you know what,
actually,
I'm convinced climate change is real.
They would lose all their friends.
Their wife would leave them,
they would lose their revenue stream.
They can't possibly come to that conclusion.
Right?
And so they fight back.
So super hard.
Right?
And so that's what ended up happening with that segment.
There's a whole group of people who have built their whole lives on the idea.
There's Alphas and Betas.
I'm an Alpha.
I'm not going to be a Beta.
Right.
Um,
and so,
and,
and maybe that misalign positive to them,
you know,
maybe they had,
were in a bad place in their life and through this model of Alpha versus Beta,
they started working out or they started,
you know,
improving themselves a little bit.
Right.
Um,
and maybe they started acting a little bit more confidently and now they're in a
relationship.
Right?
All those things can be true with the idea of Alphas and Betas and humans not
being scientific.
Right?
But so when I tell them that they fight back really hard though.
No,
no,
no.
This is,
this is real.
This is real.
You know,
and so that video,
which again,
I had no idea that would be controversial.
Got the most youtube response videos get the most,
you know,
furious at things from,
and the weirdest thing was people started to say,
this is political.
Like,
why is that in ruins?
Everything getting political.
I'm like,
I don't know what the hell they're talking about.
This is,
I have no idea.
I didn't have no idea how it's political alphas and Betas are no political.
I mean,
that's what people were saying,
I guess.
Uh,
I guess,
you know,
for some people it's become that,
but because they've seen it as part of like,
I don't know,
whatever argument they're in their head they're having about feminism or
something like that.
But to me,
I'm just like,
guys in dating right in life,
like this is not a real concept.
If you want to say,
I'm going to be confident tomorrow,
I'm not going to tell you,
that's not gonna help you out.
You know.
Um,
uh,
and you know,
I am a little bit reticent to make like a broad conclusion about evolutionary
psychology.
Right.
But I can tell you,
again,
go talk to any anthropologist,
any biologist,
and he,
you know,
sociologists.
Is there such a thing as Alpha males in humans and the strictest scientific
sense of the word
industry.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
and the,
I think they're looking at,
in terms of like winners and losers,
pushovers and people who get the job done,
you know,
confident people versus people who are not confident.
But I think you're correct.
And I think obviously humans operate on a giant spectrum.
And if you start going around saying Alpha and Beta and the,
the idea that all alphas are the same or all Betas of the same,
it's just as ridiculous as the idea of saying all democrats are the same.
We're all republicans.
It becomes an ideology.
Exactly.
Pro Male ideology.
And at Shar,
I ha the biggest problem with like overconfident men's rights guys.
Yeah.
Cause I'm like,
listen,
we have all the rights,
like
settled down.
Enough of them,
I had a whole bit about it.
It was like,
this is like divorce laws and that's it.
Everything else is stacked in our favor.
It's just fucking chill out.
You're making us look bad.
And the problems that men have
are different than the problems those guys think men have.
Right.
Um,
so for instance,
we did a segment on a stereotype.
We had an episode on stereotypes,
um,
called Adam ruins a sitcom where,
uh,
we talked about different,
you know,
we talked about stereotypes via,
sort of,
uh,
cheesy 80 sitcom had a stereotypes in it.
So you've got the stereotypical black kid,
he got the stereotypical,
an Asian kid,
he got a Syrian neighbor,
what's his name?
Do you have a gay neighbor?
No,
we didn't do that.
Well,
there's only three acts on the show.
You know what I mean?
I wish we could on that and,
and women and all sorts of things.
But we,
and we had a stereotypical dad,
you know,
like a home improvement type dad,
and,
uh,
what we talked about is like those,
there are ways that men are being harmed by the sort of narrow idea of what a
man is.
You know,
um,
for instance,
uh,
men have a very high suicide rate.
Right.
Um,
and,
uh,
specifically,
loneliness is a health problem for men,
for like older men.
Like take my dad,
right?
My Dad's a about 65.
He doesn't have a friend,
you know,
I hope he doesn't hear this,
but um,
you know,
yeah.
Like he,
he has like work colleagues.
He's got my mom,
you know,
he's got me,
he's got,
I'm sure he's got people he's friendly with,
you know what I mean?
But he doesn't have a best friend,
you know,
who doesn't,
who comes over to watch the red sox with them to is terrifying to me.
Yeah.
And the thing is,
loneliness is associated with early death and with disease.
Right?
And like when you look at the way that we bring up men,
men are socialized to not have close relationships with each other.
You know?
Yeah.
I mean,
well,
like,
uh,
we talk about,
from an early age,
we talked about this so briefly on the show,
but we could have gone into a whole episode on it from an early age.
Uh,
uh,
researchers have found this,
that,
uh,
little boys,
when they're very young,
uh,
are very close with form,
very close friendships that are physical friends with they hug,
you know,
they'll kiss,
they'll,
you know,
cause I'm the,
you know what I mean?
They'll have physical,
close friendships like that,
and then they reach an age where that starts to become not okay.
Right.
Um,
where it becomes,
oh,
that's not how boys act.
Right.
And girls are still doing that with their friends.
They're still holding hands with friends.
You know,
there's still,
uh,
you know,
having close relationships like that and boys start to start to build a little
bit of diff distance,
you know,
and,
it's easy to say,
well,
when you're a teenager,
that's because the stigma against being gay and like,
we don't want to appear gay,
but it happens even younger than like,
kids would even have a notion of that,
you know?
So it really seems to be a deep down way that we bring up boys of like,
Hey,
don't get too close to each other.
You know what I mean?
That's a little weird.
It's just a little weird for boys to do that,
you know?
And we do that.
We do it from a young age.
It's very subtle
and subtle,
but it's universal.
I mean,
in America it seems to be,
um,
and,
uh,
you know,
I,
uh,
yeah,
I've even felt that myself.
Like I've often had an easier time having close,
close relationships with,
uh,
women rather than men as friendships.
Yeah.
As friendships.
Man,
I don't,
just in terms of who I talk about,
my relationships and stuff,
you,
I have good friendships with women.
Mostly they're comics,
but almost all my good friends are guys,
a lot of good friends.
I mean,
you're lucky if that's the case.
I certainly am.
But there's this phenomenon of having little bit of distance from your male
friends,
you know,
of like
being,
of not getting really into it emotionally,
you know,
look it,
if you don't feel that way,
that's fine.
I felt that myself and I'm sure results in some people don't.
Some people feel it.
I'm sure I don't experience that.
You know,
most of my friends that I know have good male friends and they were pretty tight
with people.
Well,
when,
uh,
the,
the point is that like there is a trend,
especially in older age,
right?
It's bad.
And then my dad's name for anybody,
whether it's a male or female,
when you get older and you don't have any friends,
that's a bad scene.
Well,
so demographic.
Yeah.
We know that that happens to men more than women,
right?
That man,
my dad's age is more likely to have less friends than a woman my mom's age.
Um,
I mean,
I think that's one of those things where I would hesitate to make a big
conclusion.
But I mean,
I would say I think we can draw a link between that and you know,
that men are sort of like socialized to not have these close friendships,
but right.
So that is a serious problem that men have that men face.
Right.
Um,
another one we talk about is stuff like,
you know,
drinking and smoking for instance.
Those are behaviors that are much more pushed on that.
And you know,
those are much more advertised towards men,
right?
And those are dangerous,
Those are like hurt you physically and can lead to an early death,
right?
Those are,
those can lead to bad health outcomes.
And so those are things that men face that are different than the challenges
that women face and can result in bad health outcomes for us.
You know,
and it's so funny how the sort of like men's rights people,
you know,
they're,
they don't talk about that stuff quite as much.
They talk about,
you know,
violence and,
and,
um,
you know,
uh,
people being hurt at work and stuff like that.
Like men having dangerous occupations and that's,
and that stuff true is true as well.
But like these are the more subtle ways that,
you know,
men are,
uh,
are hurt by,
this sort of narrow expectations of what a man is that we put on men.
Hey,
men are like this.
You should be like this,
you know,
and some of those things hurt men.
Do you think we still do that?
Yeah,
we'll
still put now expectations of what man,
I told him that do I think we might be lucky here in la?
You know,
because we can sort of like live any way that we choose.
I mean,
you clearly live exactly how you want to live,
which is great.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
and,
and I get to as well.
Uh,
but I think that,
uh,
you know,
we're,
we're lucky in that we're so self actualized,
you know what I mean?
That,
that maybe we face a little bit less pressure than,
than you know,
your average Joe across the country.
Yeah.
I don't know of anyone who's putting pressure on men to not be friendly with
other men.
That seems so ridiculous to me to deny camaraderie.
Obviously in the military it's a huge aspect of military service as the
Brotherhood,
but these guys form with each other.
And that's about,
uh,
you know,
if you want to talk about traditional male values,
that's about as manly a thing as a person can do,
right.
Serve their country
very much so.
Um,
but are like men for instance,
and courage to be emotionally vulnerable with,
uh,
with their friends,
for instance.
Like I think that's something that's like,
do it,
they'll going to bring it up when you argue.
Yeah.
And so that's,
so that's the thing.
There's that,
there's a level of intimacy that were,
that were like,
and that's sort of intimacy is what leads to long friendships,
you know,
that really,
really last,
right.
It's a balancing act I think because I think there's,
there is intimacy and then there's also guys who were just being a bitch and
they need to learn how to man up.
I like this bull bull things or read things are real.
It is real to be intimate and to be vulnerable and to explain how you feel,
but then sometimes you shouldn't be just fucking complaining about things.
You should figure your life out and man the fuck up and go do something.
And it's not necessarily you being emotionally vulnerable as you like to say it
in such a,
uh,
a normalizing way might,
it might just be being a bitch.
Uh,
well to think that when you say that you put a little pressure on,
on
men at all to this,
I put pressure on men.
Yeah.
Well,
there you go.
Maybe you are,
maybe you're the one putting a little pressure.
Yes,
they need some pressure.
I think most men need just a little bit of a motivational shove in the general
direction of success and happiness.
And a lot of that is overcoming laziness and implying or,
uh,
applying some discipline to your life.
I think those things are,
let me manly attributes that turned out to actually be good for you.
Uh,
you know,
I think there's a lot of,
uh,
I don't disagree with you about,
about some of those aspects being good for you.
Um,
let,
let me just give one other example.
Um,
and I'm blanking on the name of this podcast.
I can,
I can look it up if you want,
but,
um,
uh,
very wonderful podcast about philosophy.
Um,
as far as this,
uh,
no,
I love philosophize.
This,
it's a different one here.
I'll look up what it was,
um,
as I'm talking to you about it,
but I'm really wonderful podcast.
Uh,
where,
uh,
they were talking to this guy who was in the military,
um,
and uh,
his PTSD.
And he was talking about how the idea of,
of be a man,
right?
It was just a phrase that he would hear a lot in the military,
Um,
and,
oh,
it's called hyphae nation is the name of the podcast and there's an episode
called Bia man hyphenation really wonderful podcasts about philosophy.
Um,
and,
uh,
it's was talking about that idea of Bia man,
right?
What does that mean in,
in the military?
And,
and look,
I'm just repeating with,
as in the podcast,
I have no military experience myself.
I don't want to claim too,
but,
um,
uh,
and you know,
that means sort of like overcome adversity,
right?
Don't complain too much,
If you have a problem,
solve it yourself kind of thing.
Right.
Um,
and he talked about,
and they also talked with the medical professionals who said the same thing,
that that idea,
um,
can,
doesn't give men the tools they need to deal with PTSD.
Right.
And can actually exacerbate PTSD because it means that they're not trained how
to reach out for help for those problems.
And so I think,
oh yeah,
it's a different example of,
of,
of just a way that that sort of narrow idea BIA man,
being a man means this.
A real man would do this,
right.
That does,
that works.
In some situations maybe that works when you're,
you know,
in a Foxhole,
right.
Um,
it doesn't work so well when you're out of it.
Right.
And so that's a narrow idea that can lead to a bad outcome.
Sure.
But that's basically what we were just saying,
that you know,
you should be emotionally vulnerable and know how to express yourself with your
friends and be honest and true about how you feel about things.
But you all should know when you're being a bitch.
Both of those things are real.
Fair enough.
If you're on a hike with a friend and he has to stop every five minutes because
his foot hurts,
like,
come on man,
my foot hurts to just fucking walk.
You're walking fine.
I completely,
completely agree.
We just don't think this is worth it.
This is not what I had in mind when we started hiking at guys beat a bitch,
right?
Yeah.
He needs to man the fuck up.
Right.
But let me,
but I know you're hesitant to say,
man,
the fuck up because it was a woman.
What would you say you'd say,
toughen up.
Just soldier on,
what would you say?
Well,
I don't think that the reason I'm hesitant to use that word is I don't think
that being tough is exclusively a male.
Right.
That's why I said,
if you're a woman,
what would you say?
Would you say tough enough?
Yeah,
I guess I went in the same situation.
You gotta toughen up.
You to deal with it.
Press on.
Yeah.
But men like to,
we like to equate that to one of our best attributes being a fucking man.
Cause I'm a fuck up the map.
What if you're,
what if you're a on that walkway,
on the hike with a friend and your friend is legit afraid of hikes I've been on
in France on the hikes with,
I'm sorry,
I didn't said hikes heights.
You can hike in with that dude.
And I went on a hike.
I went on a hike with a friend.
My friend had it.
We were in Zion National Park,
which has some very narrow,
that's each Utah.
Yeah.
My friend had had a panic attack.
Right.
Because,
because of the hike and it was,
and it was,
you know,
um,
and that's legit.
Right?
And thank God he was able,
he felt able to share it with me.
Right.
But if we,
you know,
so that's,
so that's the balancing act of creating an environment where you're not,
hey,
yeah,
don't complain about your foot,
but hey,
if you're really in distress,
like you can share that with me.
And some men feel that they can't do that.
And I remember when I was younger,
you know,
feeling I want to,
I really have this problem,
but I can't express that to my friends because they're going to make fun of me.
Right.
Um,
and that sucks.
And so my goal is to,
and what that segment that we did about manliness was about,
um,
was saying,
hey,
if you,
uh,
if you're a man and being a man to you means,
you know,
being confident,
being assertive and stuff like that,
great qualities,
not that qualities at all.
Right?
But we want to expand the notion of manliness.
So it includes all the different ways that one can be a man.
Right?
Um,
uh,
that,
that is,
it's as wide as possible,
right?
So because of the problem is going to shut it down,
the expression manliness,
right,
that's the problem.
Cause manliness like instantly becomes handsome,
aggressive,
you know,
muscular cultural idea of a man and womanliness is more like soft and kind.
Yeah.
You know,
you don't think of it sexually,
right?
When you see,
you think of w w womanliness isn't really a word that's used,
but if it was yeah,
womanly,
that those are their cultural ideas that we associate with those things.
Right.
But I,
so,
so let me just give you my example.
I,
uh,
personally I love taking care of other people,
right.
With me and my,
me and my girlfriend,
we've been together 10 years.
Um,
one of the main things I love to do in our relationship is I really like cooking
for her.
You know what I mean?
I like taking care of her.
That's like something that I enjoy.
Right?
Um,
uh,
that's the part of my manliness.
That's like how I am.
A man
feels good,
well food.
And you can sit down and do something for and cook for.
You can associate it with,
yeah.
Pr Providing,
providing goes back to that,
you know,
classic sort of,
uh,
Ma,
you know,
manly value you can associate with that.
I'm not even saying in that sense,
there's nothing wrong with that word,
but in that sense,
you,
you wanted give,
yeah,
exactly.
And that's not a value that I was brought up with of like,
that's a manly thing to do,
right.
Is to like,
be kind and be nurturing.
You know what I mean?
Um,
but,
uh,
it's something that I really,
that really means a lot to me.
Yeah.
It wasn't what I was brought up with.
Um,
and,
uh,
so to me it's important to like expand,
you know,
my notion of what it was really a big deal for me to like realize that that was
part of what being a man was to me.
Um,
and I noticed that like,
you know,
uh,
for instance,
um,
like let's just take the example of like,
you know,
kids entertainment,
like growing up,
you know,
like kids cartoons and stuff like that.
Like the female characters are the ones who are taking care of other people and
the male characters are the ones who are kicking ass.
Right.
And I like kicking ass sometimes too,
but I realized,
uh,
at one point I was like,
oh,
I didn't have like models of that as a kid of like,
here's a man who takes care of other people emotionally or you know,
uh,
or in a caring way,
you know,
but to fill,
uh,
Dr Phil and he does it a little bit.
It does,
it does.
It does.
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
I mean,
whenever you have a label,
it,
especially a narrow label,
it's a problem,
you know?
And I think,
uh,
the,
the idea of manliness or like what it entails and the problems that people would
have about that on the outside,
it's almost always problems that are being imposed on them.
Like,
or the ideas that are being imposed on them for people who don't like the way
they live,
they don't like who they are or want to mock who they are,
how they live.
So if someone's too emotional,
if someone's too introverted instead of celebrating that or that guy's
different.
Cool.
Yeah.
Instead of that,
it's the bully a mocking and shitting on them.
The jock type behavior.
Yeah.
We associated it with being the negative aspect of masculinity.
Toxic masculinity is,
which is the phrase that gets tossed around.
But I think this is,
um,
you know,
this is a shitty humans.
I agree.
You know,
I mean,
that's really where the problem
and it's not specific to,
it's not specific to men,
right?
It's definitely not,
it's everybody.
But let me give you one more example just to get back to what you're talking
about,
about body type and what people are attracted to.
I read this wonderful,
uh,
advice column.
Um,
uh,
it's this guy who is,
this guy doesn't device.
It's got a kind of silly names,
Dr Nerd love.
Um,
but he's doesn't really good advice column.
And this dude wrote in and said,
Hey,
I'm with a woman.
She's,
um,
you know,
a little bit bigger of a Gal,
then I've dated in the past.
I really am into her.
She's so cool,
but she's not my type.
I'm not normally into women like this.
And that bothers me that she's not my type right.
Even though I'm into her so much,
she's not my type.
What do I do about that?
She's not my type.
And I loved this guy's answer.
He wrote back and he said,
dude,
she's your fucking type.
You like her,
right?
You're into her.
You think she's a sexy woman,
right?
The problem is you are brought up in a world where it's not okay for men to like
women like that.
It's not okay to,
to like women who are her size and you've,
you've ingested at your whole life and now you're hating yourself because you
were told something that about what's okay for you to like and what's not okay
for you to like,
and I really related to that,
you know,
because I remember feeling that way about girls.
I dated like hold on a sec.
Oh,
I'm into her so much,
but oh wait,
is she not?
Is she not like attractive?
Right.
Am I wrong to be dating her because she doesn't fit what I,
you know,
the sort of like set of parameters for what an attractive woman is.
Right.
And so when you talk about what people say,
what people say they're attracted to,
if you ask any woman,
what did she say she's attracted to this kind of man,
if you ask any man wouldn't sit,
she's attracted to that kind of woman.
Yeah,
they might say that.
Right?
But deep down do they maybe have a desire that is not being,
you know,
that they,
that they've been told is wrong their whole lives.
Right.
Um,
and I really related to that,
I was like,
man,
that is really a good point.
I have been told that my whole life and it has,
I've allowed it to control who I'm attracted to to a certain extent,
you know,
and that's a mental prison that I want to get out of,
and you know,
now I have the benefit.
I'm a little bit older,
you know,
and I'm,
I feel like I'm in less mental prisons that I used to be.
I feel like you're in no mental at all at
all.
I feel like a lot of your listeners,
you know,
I've have broken out of him,
but especially I think back about like when I was 16 years old and yeah,
I,
you know,
you're swimming in that shit and you don't know to question it.
You had a lot of the time.
And that's what our show is about,
is getting people to question those assumptions and those things that you're
being told without even realizing you're being told them.
Well,
there is a problem with young men in their identities,
like them wanting other people to think them as cool as cool.
Think of them as someone who's successful or someone who's doing well.
That's a weird thing to say.
You know,
I'm,
I'm really into her but she's not my type.
But you know,
the problem there seems to,
in my mind,
in my estimation seems this guy's worry too much about his identity.
Yeah.
Instead of just being who he is,
worried about his identity and,
and that's a really tough thing to get over.
And that's what we were trying to help people get over in that episode.
But you know,
when I think about in my,
you know,
when I was getting started in comedy and my,
in my twenties,
you know,
um,
the amount of time I spent worrying before I went onstage about how,
what I was going to say I was going to come off.
It was if it was going to be cool or if I get made fun of by the other guys in
my comedy group or about like the other people at the open mic.
You know,
like I did,
I did she grow for years to come up in alt rooms.
Yeah.
The meanest mother fucker.
He sure.
Fucking art.
Super nerds.
Try it out and be like,
oh super progressive fucking mean do so God damn socially vicious,
no toe.
Especially just at the open mics in New York City.
You know,
it was a real way to say,
yeah,
yeah cause they're there.
There's no like organization.
I didn't,
I never set foot in a club because I was like,
I don't want to deal with anybody at the club thinking oh I'm trying to get a
spot or whatever.
I was like,
I'm just doing bar shows,
open mic,
stuff like that.
And yeah,
there's no rules.
So it's just social enforcement and it's just people being like,
I'm the big dog.
Like,
and people would like cross their arms during other people's sets or like say
shit and like it really fucking sucked.
And the only way I got passed it by saying I don't give a shit about what I
think of these motherfuckers think.
Yeah.
You know,
and I know I'm going to identify the people who I think are doing good work and
who I think are funny.
And then hopefully they laugh at me too.
I'm going to focus on that.
But you should look at the people that are crossing their arms with amusement
because all those fools fools,
I know what you're doing.
You're just throwing poison at people for no reason.
Totally.
You know,
especially in open mic nights and those kind of shows,
those bar shows,
people are just developing.
You know,
you're watching little babies running around in nursery home.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
And what they're trying to do with how many babies those people are trying to do
is they're trying to say,
well,
I know the difference between good and bad,
and that's one of the reasons I'm good and so on.
You say that you're bad,
right?
That's bullshit.
It's bullshit.
And a lot of them aren't funny,
and that's a real part of the problem.
They're trying to enforce a narrow band of comedy because they think they can
operate inside those parameters.
But if they wanted to go on stage at the comedy store after Joey Diaz,
they'd burst into flames.
That's I'm really that good.
Yeah.
No,
what you're doing is not that good.
I know you think you have a point,
but what you're saying is not your art,
is it?
Not that I know that you listened to the [inaudible] podcast and you think that
makes you go in everybody,
but the number of people who'd be like,
well it billboard wouldn't do it like that or whatever.
Like that kind of thing is like so,
so off the off the charts
vintagey you know it really is and the best,
the best energy in the small groups,
the best way to use your energy is to appreciate good work and recognize bad
work and recognize maybe you have some of that aspect totally and yourself,
some some aspects of bad work and your own act and maybe you should trim it out
and look at yourself objectively.
The way you're looking at this person,
but the whole cross your arms and let someone stealing or doing something racist
or,
or clearly fucked up socially,
you know,
like what do you care?
You care.
They just,
they just suck.
You suck too bro.
Yeah.
You're in the open mic at 11:00 PM you both of them went for three hours to do
three minutes,
you know,
so it's like your first couple of years on stage was terrible.
I want to go back and hug everyone who's ever in the audience and say,
I'm sorry I didn't mean to put you through whatever the fuck I did up there.
That 10 minutes of nonsense.
I'm sorry.
One time when I was doing open Mikes,
I was doing,
I was doing three up on Mike's at night in New York,
you know,
and I've kind of missed that.
I was like really fun.
It was like going to the gym,
you know,
it's like bouncing around Bob up a pump,
but you know,
you really get used to it.
And there was one night,
I can't remember why the hell this happened,
but my girlfriend and her friend,
um,
and they're both cartoonists.
My girl,
my girlfriend is a incredible,
uh,
cartoonists,
on her name's Lisa Hanawalt.
Um,
uh,
and so she's funny.
You know,
these are funny people for some reason were like,
we want to come to the open mic at the creek and cave in New York.
I was like,
she do okay,
here we go.
And they sat there and they were like,
we sat in the front row and they were like,
their,
their hands were like covering their eyes.
They were like,
oh,
like every single person because he,
what is he doing?
Oh my God,
this person.
What were they thinking?
Like they were,
they was just like the worst freak show to them.
And I was like,
yeah,
I do this every single night.
Like everything that,
every shitty mistake or every weird thing that every person did that I was
totally like blank to that I'd seen a million times.
They were like shocked by what was going on on that stage.
Um,
and it made me really enjoy going to those mikes again cause it made me see for
the first time,
you know,
like,
uh,
made me fresh again to like how fucking weird I miss up a Mike so much because
it's such a beautiful disaster,
right?
Cause you're right,
every single person that goes up at an open mic is sweating.
W basically they're doing like,
they're like endurance training.
Like they're doing something that is physically uncomfortable,
even socially terrible and they're bad at it and they're just doing it over and
over again until they get used to it.
Um,
so that they can just go up on stage without flop sweating.
You know,
like everyone just watching,
uh,
a hundred people in a row have panic attacks basically and people are just being
there weird fucking selves and you see a lot of nonsense.
And then you see a lot of people where you're like,
God damn,
that person is,
there is a core there and then they're going to be really fucking funny.
And I love the fact that I know so many people from those days,
we've just all grown up together.
And now they're all right in sitcoms or they're doing it.
You know,
I met Michelle Wolf our first week doing open mikes.
Um,
it was so cool.
We've met like,
I was like my second open mic and it was like her third open mic and we saw each
other at her and a couple friends.
I was like,
you guys are funny.
You're funny.
And she was like,
yeah,
we're going to sit there.
Mike,
you want to come?
Yup,
let's go.
And then I've known her ever since and then like to see her do that white horse
core White House correspondence dinner was like,
I just felt all that history all at once.
I was like,
this is fucking amazing.
You know?
I was so what did you think when the president was tweeting at her?
I was like,
damn,
she got him on the hook.
I was like,
that's what a comic supposed to do.
You know,
like the way that she pissed people off.
That was such a beautiful,
that was such a beautiful moment.
I loved it.
She was so fucking funny and great writing too.
It was great,
right?
Yeah.
She wrote it,
a bunch of our friends from those days,
Anthony to veto Greg stone.
Dan Saint Germain I believe,
help to write jokes and yeah,
they were really funny.
And guess what?
Like the crowd didn't want comedy apparently,
but they got one of the best comics in the country.
You know who's like on that?
She's in her prime right now and she fucking tore it up.
She did her job better than they wanted and they got pissed off about it and it
was,
it was like a three day news cycle of how much,
but everybody hated her were there,
didn't get pissed off.
Some of them,
they were like tweeting like Maggie Haberman for the New York Times was tweeting
like,
oh I feel bad for,
you know Sarah Huckabee like for the,
for the,
you know,
light jab that she got about her high makeup that was smear break thing.
It was nothing.
And they were talking about what they say shit,
appearance,
shamed.
She appearance sheet.
Yeah.
I forget what it was.
She,
she got off light.
Everybody got off light.
Yeah,
that's great and fine.
But people forget when cold bear did that 10 years earlier and he was a
applauded for it.
The people in the room hated that too.
If you go back and watch that video,
he gets no laughs when he's making fun of Bush,
one of the most famous like comedy appearances ever,
right?
Yeah.
And he got zero laughs in the room.
It's dead quiet.
It's bizarre if you watch it.
And then a year later it was like [inaudible] he's the master,
he did it,
Dah,
Dah.
That was one of the big moments for comedy,
getting serious and like sat targeting that was a breakout for him and like the
political hacks in the room can't take it because they don't,
I don't know why they book comics because they do not want comedy and that's why
they,
I guess they're,
you know,
they're not going to book comedy anymore,
but here's an interesting cat man.
Yes,
yes.
A bunch of things rolled up into one because he's a,
he's a legitimate Catholic,
like,
yeah,
really Catholic.
Yeah.
Despite all the scandals and kid fucking and all the craziness.
And then on top of that,
he's this character,
but now he's not the anymore.
No.
Now he's like a guy who's not totally playing the character,
but the character comes in and out like little shadows.
Yes,
it does.
And it's like,
what are you,
what's your real thoughts on things?
Cause I know you as Cole Bear and know you from the Colbert report,
this hilarious fake Republican guy and now I'm seeing him.
I'm not sure what's going on here,
man.
Yeah.
I mean he's,
well,
and when you're,
when you're in late night,
you know,
I play a character on my show too.
That's like a heightened version of myself that's developed as like a very extra
nerdy,
it's almost like me as peewee Herman,
a little bit like it's,
it's a,
it towards me is my younger self.
It's like very socially awkward.
I'm alone.
Oh,
sorry.
Like it's a lot of up there,
you know,
and it's different than what I do on stage.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
I can only imagine,
even though he is still,
he's like,
his big thing for late night was like,
I'm going to be myself.
I'm not the character anymore.
You still build a little bit of a character for yourself,
you know also the him,
it's like that's what brought them to the dance.
Yeah.
The reason why you're there.
It's like what,
what kind of meetings that they have with him.
Like what are we going to do here?
I have this trait,
I ain't going to be gold bear.
I heard him say once,
he only said this in one interview,
but he was like,
we're basically creating a new character for late night.
And so he had the same writers from,
from the Colbert report.
And so,
uh,
he was like,
we're sort of like creating a new character.
How does this character work?
But I got to say the old show,
I mean he's,
he's great.
The old show was probably the best performance ever made by a single late night
comics because the way that he,
when I watch it now,
if I go back and watch clips,
I'm like the way he would do like three or four fast little turns,
you know,
single line where it would like mean one thing but there'd be some sub tax.
Then he would flip around and he would do it like it was like watching like a
figure skater do triple axles,
you know,
like watching him do that.
It was,
it was really impressive.
I liked the guy,
don't get me wrong,
but I like him more on the Colbert report and I'm like him as a late night talk
show host.
But I do have to agree.
I think that's also my prejudice against that format.
I'm like,
you guys just saw what Jack Parr did and kept going.
Totally.
It's the same goddamn thing.
But I understand why he couldn't do the cold,
but he did that show for like 10 years,
you know,
like he can't,
you can't do,
there was a limited thing for him,
you know,
like he had that character and so he could only do what was in the box,
that character.
And so he's looking to do more and,
and I get it.
I also feel like,
man,
that Colbert report is more interesting than the late night show to me as a
comic.
And it was a comedy writing fan for sure.
Because the late night shows her just promotion shows,
that's all they are.
All they are is,
Hey Adam,
here you have a book out.
Hey Mike,
tell us about your new show.
Here's our 10 minutes of comedy before that.
And then we do that.
Yeah.
It's basically like a version of a commercial and the w and the nightly thing is
a prison,
you know,
because you can only talk about what happened that day.
So the smartest thing that you know,
John Oliver,
right?
He was up for the daily show.
He wanted to do the daily show.
He was John Stewart's pick for the daily show.
They said this in the,
in the oral history book of the daily show.
And then comedy central didn't close the deal with Oliver and HBO came and said,
do you want to do a show instead?
You know,
and John Stewart was like,
all right,
go with God.
And that's what John Oliver did instead.
So we living in that alternate reality from John Oliver Hosting the daily show.
Right?
And so the smartest thing I'll ever did was do weekly,
not daily because it lets him go wider.
Right.
If he was doing daily,
he would have to just talk about what happened that day.
You don't have that much.
You don't guess what,
you can't have as much of a complete thought in 24 hours or in realistically the
six hours you have between when you show up.
But when you take the shuttle,
right,
you can't say as much [inaudible] it's harder.
And so being on that,
you know,
weekly schedule and he's only doing 30 something shows a year,
right?
Cause they have hiatuses.
That's what allows them to have those big,
long complete thoughts that everyone likes so much.
You know,
these ramps,
intelligent takes your news issues and pointing out hypocrisy.
Our show,
it takes us,
we,
it takes us like three or four months to write an episode.
Like we're writing 16 at once,
but like,
you know,
that's how long we have to think about it.
And so we're able to take twists and turns,
you know,
we go into it thinking this is going to be our angle and then we're,
we're diving into the research.
We have a wonderful research staff and they say,
actually this is the more interesting part of the story and then we are,
have the time to go chase it that way instead.
Right.
Whereas if we were on a daily schedule,
oh shit.
Well we don't have time to pivot because we got a show to make.
Right.
You ever feel time constraints in terms of like the subject matter,
the subject matter,
like very,
very involved.
Yeah,
I mean,
we try to do the most difficult topics.
We can't,
you know,
we don't hold back from anything.
Um,
but the only constraint that we have is that the show,
we've got 21 minutes and then in,
but we got commercials.
So we only talk about some for six minutes before we have to move on.
Right.
And so that's the,
that's the only limitation that we have.
Like the network will let us do anything.
We've been on the show for weed on the network for four years.
The only time you've ever killed a show was we want to do something about the
Ncaa,
about how the NCAA shouldn't kill,
I shouldn't kill,
sorry.
Shows us how it should pay athletes.
Right.
Well,
in the case of football and just going there,
but yeah,
we'd talk about that all the time.
I think it is one of the craziest fucking scams in,
in all of money,
let it college sports or it's unbelievable.
Making so much money off those kids.
When you watch those things,
every single person's getting paid,
you know,
everybody's getting paid.
The Guy,
best players,
the guy bringing water to the announcers are getting paid except for the
players.
Right.
So,
and the guy who literally,
I'm blanking on his name,
but the guy who created the system,
right,
who like formed the NCAA layer.
When he left,
he compared it to plantation slavery.
He was like,
this is like slavery.
What I invented,
you know,
there's no justification for it at all.
It is a banana's.
Uh,
we want to do that topic for a college episode.
We pitched that to true TV.
Uh,
you know what errors on true TV every march,
March madness,
March madness.
And they said no.
They said,
they said,
and here's,
here's how I live with myself.
I say,
look,
I will never take a no until it's the only absolute answer I can get.
So they said,
no.
I say,
I really want to do it.
Tell me know again.
You know,
they told me no again.
I was like,
if the president of the network tells me no,
then I'm not doing it.
And the president of network told me no,
because that's the guy who I could write it and he could tell the episodes.
Well,
that's true.
I shouldn't have NCAA on.
You're worried about.
They're worried about pissing off,
not just the NCAA.
Yeah.
Piss off those money grubbing thieves,
athletic kids.
I'm with you.
All these people are paying money to see those fucking kids.
That shit drives me crazy exploiting of young athletes in college.
His workers.
It is one of the ones that drives me because I got into it with Joey Diaz who
explained to me,
cause Joey used to be a bookie and he really understands gambling.
He was explaining to me how much money gets donated to the schools,
but people who used to go to them heels.
It's insane.
Yeah.
And he sent,
and most of it is based on the performance that the school has in college sports
and these people who are,
you know,
I'm a fucking,
Blah Blah Blah.
I went to school there and I'm there at all.
I die,
I fucking go team.
These assholes throw shit.
Tons of money.
And there's thousands of them all throughout history,
years and years.
Guys have been donating for 25 fucking years.
Yup.
And when the team wins the championship,
they give him a bonus doing even more,
right?
Yes,
but who doesn't get the money as the kid
king?
People who play the game,
all they have to do so well.
If you go through here,
you're going to do education and then you're good to go to pro sports.
How many of them make it,
especially in football,
almost none.
Almost none.
But look at what are the numbers?
What is it like?
I wonder what the numbers are guys who sign up for college football,
who make it first of all,
with a body that's functional after four years of 600 fucking pound,
dude slamming that big giant,
giant dude slamming into you.
You know fun.
We did.
We did an episode on football and the concussion to Emma's,
not just concussions,
right?
It's like just the little hits,
It's just the routine tackles.
You know what I mean?
What happens every single time you do that,
your brain,
you got to think of it this way.
Your brain is riding your,
your skull is the car.
Your brain's a passenger.
Your brain doesn't have a seat belt,
right?
Every time you run into somebody,
boom,
your brain slides forward a little bit cause it's not wearing a seatbelt bumps
into the front of your skull and bounces back,
right.
And even if that doesn't cause a concussion,
it causes a little,
a little hurt every single time,
right?
And so you can never get a concussion do that over and over and over again,
and you're going to end up with CTA.
And so of trauma happens and soccer players,
yeah,
sandy gets you in soccer and those kids or those kids are hurting themselves,
you know,
uh,
and they're not getting paid for it.
Jamie wrote here in football out of 73,557 NCAA presents a fence.
Approximate number of who are draft eligible is down to 16,346 and now down to
draft picks,
it's 256 [inaudible] 56 out of 73,000 make it to draft
1.6% make it from the NCAA to the 1.6%
ridiculous.
Ncaa to major pro 1.6% that is fucking crazy.
Let's be honest,
these kids are not getting a full education as POWs.
Baseball is almost 10% way more teams with like miners and all that kind of
crazy though.
That's wild.
So what 10% that's weird.
Well the though,
but that's,
oh that's 10% of from draft eligible to drafted the major banks,
not even the participants because look that's,
that's a 35 k seven seven K or draft eligible and then seven joint seven are
drafted.
Right,
but look how low the number is in terms of baseball participants versus
football.
It's half less than half and yet they have way higher percentage.
This is our writing consults.
We look at charts also.
The thing is like with baseball you don't get hit right unless you get hit by a
ball.
Most of the time your injuries just from running or sliding and stuff like that.
Yeah.
You're not going to hit that well.
You can get,
yeah,
you can get hit in the head with a baseball.
So much safer.
If I had a kid and the kid was thinking like baseball,
football,
or basketball,
I'd be like,
we'll take that foot ball out of the fucking equation.
You've got two choices.
It was don't do it.
Just don't do it.
You're not going to make it.
No.
The very few people that make it out of there without like serious injury,
it's like,
it's not worth it.
It's just not.
Especially if you look at that 75,000 number,
if you look at,
uh,
for how many kids are playing in the NCAA now think about how many kids were
playing high school football.
I don't know the number,
but it's gotta be 10 times that.
Right.
This kid is going to be,
he's the Heisman trophy winner and he already has been drafted to the major
league baseball,
but he's also projected to potentially be in a top five NFL picks.
Whoa.
So there's like a big discussion on what should he do?
It's up to him obviously,
but players like Deion Sanders,
who I've been in both leagues and I've done both at the same time.
It's like play baseball.
Wow.
Oh Man.
Well that's better for your life because you're less,
you're less likely to,
to like,
yeah,
I have brain damage.
Do you ever talk to a fucking baseball player that's retired?
It's like talking to a regular person.
He still does.
He still wants to be the quarterback,
not going to be a basketball player.
Those guys clearly have the best of it.
Like out of all the major sports basketball players because they,
I don't know about that because it's a much more grueling schedule.
Physically you're running and shooting every night,
you're sprinting,
you're doing all these different things.
Baseball is so much more leisurely,
but the celebrity aspect of basketball is so huge and like in baseball,
baseball should I can't he rod and it's still theirs.
Five,
10 min,
Max,
10 guys on the court.
And if you do anything cameras right on your face.
Yeah.
Versus like the head of home ground baseball.
This was pointed out to me,
the website deadspin did this thing where they were like pointing out the
problem with baseball today.
They went around,
they ask people,
hey can you name or what's the most famous baseball player that you could name?
And people were like Derek Jeter,
a rod,
big Papi,
Manny,
Manny Ramirez,
retired guys.
And if you ask people,
they could,
men,
if they're a baseball fan,
they'd say someone from my team or maybe they'd say Mike Trout or say one of the
guys in the Yankees.
Right.
But there is no a rod Jeter like level celebrity right now.
What happened?
I don't know exactly.
I can't give him back the steroids.
No one's getting hurt.
What the fuck is the problem?
We're not talking about fighting.
We're talking about baseball.
Give him the steroids.
The best part about that stupid games with someone hits the ball.
Does the steroids make them hit the ball better?
Yes.
Okay.
Well give it to him.
The fuck are you guys doing testing for that?
Performance enhancing drugs man are the craziest the debate about that.
We've never done this on the show because I so I'm not like um,
you shouldn't fully boned up.
I would like to,
I've thought about it in the past cause cause the,
the divisions,
it's like the rest of the drug war,
right?
The divisions we make between the things that are acceptable and not acceptable
are so arbitrary.
Right?
So the example I always use is like,
okay,
why don't,
why don't we like it?
Performance enhancing drugs.
Not everyone has access to them.
So they're unfair,
right?
There are bad for your health and we think they're unnatural.
Right?
Okay.
So,
yeah,
there,
there.
Yeah.
Well that's,
those are the reasons why we think they're cheating.
Right?
Well,
it's also,
but there are some drugs you can take that aren't cheating,
right?
Like you could take a,
the reason why it's cheating.
That's the primary reason.
So here's,
so let me give you a counter example.
Um,
uh,
for runners,
right?
Uh,
for endurance athletes like me,
I like running.
I'm a shitty runner,
but I like it.
I think it's a fun sport.
Um,
so I follow it a little bit.
Uh,
so runners,
endurance,
you know,
the big thing is like how much you're,
how much oxygen your blood can hold,
right?
If you train at a high altitude,
then you can increase that.
Right?
So there are these runners,
the American runners,
right?
They live at a high altitude,
they live super high up,
you know,
in Colorado or whatever.
Right.
And then when they're not there,
they train,
they're all year round.
They buy a place there and then when they're not there,
when they're competing somewhere else,
they sleep in a chamber that simulates low altitude.
Right.
How is that not the same thing as taking a performance enhancing drug?
Like they,
they,
you know,
it's not a,
it's not illegal to do that.
Right,
right.
It's unnatural.
Right?
It is an unfair advantage because not everybody can afford one of those
chambers.
And I'm not gonna say it's bad for your health,
I don't know.
But it's certainly as weird for your body has taken a drug,
I would think.
Right.
So why it's not because it's only like living at altitude.
It's really just simulates low altitude.
It's not like taking EPO,
which would be the drug that would simulate that,
which I've got recent,
uh,
experience with,
not personally,
but because of the UFC.
Just had one of its champions stripped because of testing positive for EPO.
And then we're just finding out now they don't test for EPO in everybody that
it's very expensive.
And so they do it based on the athlete's biological passport and what they think
are changing variables that,
you know,
for whatever reason it triggers their,
their interest.
Yeah.
We start testing additionally,
it's a big deal.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a serious drug.
I mean it's a serious endurance drug but also has some serious health
complications.
People have died from taking it.
A young guys in their twenties and cycling have gotten strokes and died from
EPA,
but there's no health negative effects of sleeping at altitude.
It's just can you afford to live there?
Can you grab route your life?
No,
if you can't,
yeah,
it's an advantage for that person over you.
So I'm just saying we have a,
we have sort of an ar,
like it's sort of an arbitrary where we're drawing the lines is not consistent
and it's kind of that,
that is a big one.
The,
that in terms of uh,
the impact on endurance,
it is a big one.
They're actually saying now that they think the best um,
best course of strategy is to train at low altitude and then sleep at high
altitude.
They think that when you train at low altitude you have more output so you're
putting in more repetitions because you get more oxygen so you have more work
and then you get the same effect by living at altitude.
So you get,
you get up there and sleep and you don't have to train up there and if you train
up there,
it's actually slightly less valuable than training at low altitude and staying
up there damn.
Cause whatever I'm whenever,
whenever I'm stands and where High Alto,
like I just did a weekend in Denver and I was like going on a run up there and
it was like obviously torture compared to like being here in la.
But I was like,
oh I'm getting strong cause I'm running at high altitude.
That's not true.
That really fucks with me.
Well you just really need something from me.
Thank you.
It's work and it will help you,
but it's if you're a nap like athletes or we're literally working for one or 2%
of an advantage.
Occasionally on many occasions when you are living at high altitude and training
at sea level,
they think that that gives you a slight advantage because you can put more work
in,
especially for fighters,
they think that skilled work and repetitions and drilling is one of the most
important aspects of it.
And you can just simply get in more repetitions,
you can get in more drills.
Hmm.
Yeah.
But they,
you know,
again though you're right cause this is sort of a performance enhancing thing.
You're not just living and just being yourself and then showing up and
competing.
Yeah.
You are engaging in this activity that re significantly raises your red blood
cells significantly raises your oxygen capacity,
Changes Your Cardio,
your vo two Max changes.
Yeah.
Here's,
here's the word that it's just,
just this,
there's this weird idea in sports and look,
you know,
Shit love more about athletics cause then I do,
it's not my,
it's not my real forte,
but I,
you know,
I do enjoy it.
And the thing that's always weird to me is that we have this idea that like
there's some kind of level playing field that the,
there's this like baseline human that we can just say,
well,
you've got to be at the baseline,
right?
Yeah.
And humans are so variable.
You're always going to find these weird cases.
And when you try to adjudicate it gets really weird.
Like,
do you know about,
you know,
casters Romania?
You know who she is?
No.
Uh,
oh no.
I do know this.
Do I tell this story?
This story pisses me off so much.
So she's a mess.
She's not a marathon,
right?
She's a middle distance runner.
I believe she's south,
South African.
Um,
she's like the best in the world at the 200 meters.
You know,
I actually got to see her because,
uh,
my,
I went to the Prefontaine classic in Eugene,
Oregon with my
dad to like watch the big track meet,
you know,
best in the world.
People,
this is like a Olympics,
you know,
not qualifier,
but it's like the Olympic caliber athletes saw her.
She's incredible.
Just like one of the best in the world.
She's got,
um,
a,
uh,
she,
her whole life has faced accusations that she,
uh,
that her,
that she's a man basically,
um,
because she has like an elevated level of testosterone or,
and this is our natural body,
right?
And so she's had to deal with people saying,
oh,
we gotta,
we gotta do a sex check on you,
which is humiliating and like also completely unscientific,
you know,
like what,
what are they going to do?
Um,
and uh,
one look at her genitals.
Well,
here's the weird thing man,
is that yeah,
they want to look at her genitals first of all,
which is humiliating to have that happen.
If you're an athlete,
you're like,
the people have to be in the room.
This is the problem,
right?
How do you judicate that?
Right,
right.
And also,
there's such a thing,
I don't know anything about her personal situation.
Right.
There's such a thing as Intersex people,
right?
Where when you look at the generals,
you can't tell.
It's not like,
hey,
just look at their junk.
And you can tell,
right,
this is a real phenomenon.
Like 1% of people are Intersex,
right?
Isn't that high?
Uh,
I was speaking off the top of my head,
but it's higher than you think.
You know,
it's definitely hard.
It's a nonzero number of people,
right?
Intersex people are a real thing.
Um,
and so,
uh,
so,
but so she got past that,
right?
They stopped challenging whether she was like a man or a woman.
They did it by Amazon Test Center.
Uh,
I think you might be right.
Yeah.
Um,
but so she's,
she's had a deal with that.
That's not fair.
Right?
She's a physical cause,
a physical outlier.
And now the IAF,
which is the organization that runs all,
it's like FIFA for track,
right?
They run all track.
They have tried to put forward a rule.
I don't know what the status is right now because it's being challenged.
But,
um,
they've tried to put forward a rule that says if you have a testosterone level
over a certain amount,
you have to take a hormone changing to change your hormones and she's going to
fall under that.
And so they literally want to change the body that she was born with because
they're saying your body is unfair to her.
How fucked up is that?
Right.
That's crazy.
It's really,
really fucked up.
And,
and so the thing is when we make those decisions about what's fair and what's
not fair,
there's no baseline.
Human is always a value judgment.
And when we're excluding some people,
that's almost all,
we always need to look at that and say,
are we discriminating?
They're definitely discriminating against Castro,
Romania.
And is this the IOC?
That's what does doing this?
And what does the IAA f which is the IOC,
is the Olympics Iaf.
The Olympics aren't doing this,
so they don't have an issue with her.
I don't know what the Olympic policy is.
The Olympics is fucked up.
We had a whole episode on the Olympics.
The Olympics is fucked up in a lot of ways too dirty,
dirty,
oh incredibly Darlene's of dollars off those athletes who worked for free.
We had this dude on a shot put guy who uh,
gold medalist in the shot put.
He was like the year I had a gold medal,
I was not able to pay my bills,
you know.
Um,
and he is literally trying to like unionize the athletes,
which is very hard,
right.
Cause there's new athletes every four years.
But yeah,
those athletes are not paid.
Plus no one's going to listen to the guy who throws the heavy roles.
What do you do?
Do you want a hundred meters?
Yeah,
I got a gold medal for the hockey to hook a cannon ball.
I'll use throw a rock.
We're that you can't make a living throwing rocks,
dude.
Sorry.
It's fucked up though because people watch those people watch the sports,
you know the most fucked up things when they let the NBA play.
Yeah.
They left the NBA play get something.
Poor Eastern block nations.
Yeah.
You've got these fucking,
you know,
super athletes who are professional American and they literally like all players
for the,
for the biggest ones,
they can,
um,
uh,
you know,
get spa.
Michael Phelps can just,
can you get a sponsorship right?
For the biggest one,
the biggest ones,
but the lower ones can't get sponsorships and like the put people can't get
sponsorships and they're also not even allowed to promote themselves using the
Olympics.
They can't be like,
Hey,
pizza place.
You know,
I'll be,
I'll be on an Olympic athlete.
Me,
you know,
and the pizza place,
because if they use the word Olympics,
the IOC will sue them.
Geez.
So yeah,
it's really,
really,
really not fair.
It's so prestigious.
If you can win a gold medal in the Olympics,
I mean,
you basically can,
you have a fitness career for life.
Yeah.
But well,
you could figure it out.
You're going to be a high school coach for the rest of your life depending on
the sport,
depending on the sport.
Right?
Like shot put a shot,
but I don't know what your prospects are.
Right.
Um,
fuck bro.
You're throwing rocks.
Something that people enjoy,
like track.
I like track and field,
which sucks.
Has is one of the dirtiest of all the sports but it's my favorite one to watch.
Why is that a part of track and field?
The rock throwing part.
How the fuck he has a track or field.
What are you doing?
Are you a human catapults?
Are you at the top of a need of the dude that they put on the top of the bridge
for a rock?
I like this where someone has to like ride a horse then shoot a gun,
then go for a swim the old time.
Shut it.
Yeah.
There's some stupid fucking sports in the Olympics.
Sorry my Canadian friends.
But curling,
curling is the top of the heap currently is getting bigger and bigger.
The postures,
they don't have Jujitsu in the Olympics and they don't know.
Okay.
That's fucked up.
Yeah.
Retired NFL guys currently trying to make the curling team that just based off
of a bet that he'd made with his drunk buddies.
Like I bet I could do it.
That he could do it for sure.
Having a tough time actually.
Cause that they are,
but like the drunk didn't,
not even try trying.
It's just the,
you know,
the systems we use to organize these things are so important.
You know,
it's like so much more about like,
here's a really good example of this.
I thought this is fascinating.
Like,
um,
India,
right?
A country of over a billion people,
Huge number of people has almost no Olympic athletes.
Right.
And I'm like the first guy wrestlers don't of wrestlers,
I'm not sure,
but the,
I remember this because a couple Olympics ago,
the first individual gold medalist ever from India won a gold medal and he
wanted an air pistol,
which is like a shooting.
That's my shit shooting.
Oh yeah.
No,
I had never heard of it before.
Right.
He's independently wealthy and had just practiced and practiced and practiced.
What they don't have is India is,
it's a great country.
It's not a very organized country.
They have a lot of infrastructure
in terms of,
you know,
we've got teams,
right?
Whereas in the U s we devote tons of money,
government money,
private money to like,
you know,
the swimming us swimming,
billions of dollars,
people training science,
Dah,
Dah.
In India they don't have that,
right?
Right.
So despite the fact that they have so many people,
they got a billion people,
they must have every time.
They must have one of the world's strongest people.
They must have won the world's fastest people cause they got a billion people.
Right.
What they don't have is that training infrastructure,
right?
So if you look at it that way,
you're like,
okay,
hold on a second.
We don't like performance enhancing drugs because unearned unfair advantage.
Well,
what else is training infrastructure than an unfair advantage?
If you're born in the u s you have a way better chance of making it to the
Olympics and becoming that greatest athlete in the world and someone in the,
in India,
how is that fair?
How is that not an unfair advantage?
You know?
That's true.
But
to play devil's advocate,
if you were state sponsored athlete from Russia or China,
you have a much better than you do.
If you're an American and you're some shotput put dude who doesn't have a way to
make a living in total you bills while you're working for the Olympics,
you totally do.
So my point is there's no right
baseline human like there's no,
there's no way to eliminate all advantages and never,
you know,
and just say,
oh no,
it's just what you came is just what you were born with.
Right.
You know,
it doesn't exist.
There's no such thing.
Men who are running with that w I'm sorry,
what's her name again?
[inaudible] those women who are running with her,
they just shit happens bro.
You know,
if you're a heavyweight boxer and you grew up in the era of Mike Tyson,
yeah,
I'm sorry,
but this is just what you're stuck with.
This is what's going on.
And some people are just,
they just have advantages.
They just have advantages physically,
mentally,
and there's outliers.
You found it.
Sorry.
You got an outliner.
Might want to do something else.
Yeah.
APPS.
I know.
What race is that Lee's going to run.
I don't run those races.
Yeah.
Run a different,
not a different race.
That's always been money you feel about trans athletes,
you know?
Uh,
it's a good,
it's a good question.
I think it's,
we're really going to go through like a cultural
change on how we think about that.
You know,
it's,
it's morphing so quickly,
you know what I mean?
Um,
uh,
I'm very much because I am of this opinion that there is no such thing as like
perfect fairness.
And when we make those distinctions,
we're always choosing who to allow and because I think we should choose to allow
like trans people to participate in society.
I'm for an inclusive approach where,
you know,
we're able to like find a,
find like a model that allows those folks to compete fairly in a way that
everybody's happy with.
I think that's the,
I think that's what we should do,
you know?
Um,
and that to me is like,
that's what makes me like sports more,
you know?
Um,
is those comparisons like,
um,
you know,
another thing that pissed me off so much was like,
uh,
oh fuck.
What's his name?
The um,
the disabled runner who then killed his girlfriend.
Oh yeah.
The,
the story,
a story,
the story is right.
And people were saying about this guy that his,
that his a prosthetic gave him an advantage.
Now first of all,
there's no fucking way that's true because he doesn't have muscles,
muscles converting food into does give you an advantage.
I mean to do things.
So I think mechanically does cause their
springs.
They essentially,
the way his leg works with those things is you play,
you've seen him,
right?
They don't even look remotely like feet.
Yeah.
It's a crazy like,
but dude,
the,
he's hold on that,
that's not an advantage because how mechanics work,
right?
Is that a spring you put energy into it and you get a little bit less energy
out.
Right.
So cause that's the laws of thermodynamics,
right?
You can get more out than you put in,
except a muscle does give you more than you put in because a muscle converts
food into energy for a brief period.
Right.
And so he does,
he has sprint,
he doesn't have springs.
Sorry.
He has springs.
He doesn't have a machine in his leg.
The way the rest of us do that creates force out of food.
Well,
you know,
question is whether or not the lower half of his legs,
which is what he's missing,
could make up for the,
the advantage,
the mechanical advantage of the shape of those things,
which applies all sorts of really unusual leverage when you're running.
Totally.
You're not,
I mean I don't,
I don't know if it's,
I mean,
I don't know if you took him with full legs and took him with those things if
they'd run the same amount of time.
But the thing that we can run fast as fuck with those things you've seen those
guys,
well he could write,
but where's all the other double amputees who are like,
you know,
calming of the Marine Track and field.
How many of them are trying to pair Olympics is huge.
There's like a ton of Paralympic athletes.
You know,
like I've been told that it has an mechanical advantage by someone who actually
should know what they're talking about.
But I want to,
I would like to look it up.
Do those um,
legs,
horse's legs.
I hard.
I remember reading stuff at the time from,
you know,
uh,
exercise,
whatever,
uh,
athletic scientists forget what it's called.
Um,
who said that?
Who said that?
It didn't,
right.
but so that's a debate that we could have.
Right?
But the point that I was trying to make was looking at that Olympics.
God,
that's a better event with that guy in it.
You know,
I'm so happy he was in it.
Right?
Like if it does give you an advantage when he comes in second place,
you know?
Well,
so,
so the point is when we make the rules of a game,
right?
And this is the point of our episode about Games,
which is about the Olympics.
Actually,
when we make the rules of a game,
we are,
there's no such thing as a perfectly fair competition that would be designed by
God to be perfect and be perfectly fair.
Right?
Right.
We're always making choices about what kind of competition we want to have and
what,
who we want to allow into it and what sort of outcome we want to have.
You know what I'm in,
right?
Just like in baseball,
too many home runs move the mount up or down.
You know how they change the rules a little bit because they want more homeruns
same thing with same thing with track and field.
We changed the rules a little bit to allow this person and not allow this
person.
Right.
I think that when we're talking about people,
we should always try to include more people,
not less.
We should,
you know,
like if and if,
hey,
if you're a double amputee and you can get your way into the Olympics and you
can make a plausible case,
I think we should try to entertain that notion and we should try to find a way
to get that guy in there.
Right.
As far as trans athletes go,
you know,
we could have,
we could sit here and talk for three hours about like all the different ways
that hormones might affect your body.
It might not your body,
and I'm not
an expert on that and I don't want to claim to be right.
But a sports with a trans athletes who are,
uh,
you know,
competing with the,
with their gender,
right?
That's,
uh,
that is a sporting world that I'm Morgan trusted in.
Right?
And I think we should find a way to make that happen.
I know it can be really complicated,
complicated and messy,
right?
Um,
and,
uh,
there's gonna be a lot debate about it and it's gonna make it's gonna be
uncomfortable,
you know,
and gonna be a lot of arguments.
But,
you know,
I hope that that's the world that we've moved forward to.
That's my,
that's my point of view.
My point of view is that there's a reason,
there's a distinction.
There's a reason why we make the distinction to have male athletics versus
female athletics.
The reason is that males have a physiological,
physiological advantage over women.
So in most sports,
most physical sports,
we do not have males compete with females.
The question becomes when someone who was male transitions and becomes female,
do those same physiological advantages apply?
And what are the,
what is the evidence?
Well,
the evidence and competition seems to be that it shows that it does apply,
particularly in weightlifting,
rugby,
mountain biking power,
heavy sports that are,
that favor larger people,
stronger bodies,
males that transition to females have a significant advantage and they're
breaking world records.
So if you're a woman and you're a natural woman and you don't take any extra
hormones or male hormones,
you're not taking steroids or any sort of performance enhancing drugs,
you're doing your very best to compete and you're at the top of the heap.
But then someone comes along that was a man for 30 years and decides that
they're going to be a woman and this has happened and literally transition a few
months ago and compete as a woman and destroys records and dominates you in that
sport.
That's bullshit.
And that's not competing on a level playing field.
That's a,
a person who is biologically a male and who was a male for 30 plus years of
having testosterone run through their body and affect their tendon strength and
affect the shape of their bones and the mechanical advantages of the male hips
versus the female hips.
And then they're competing with smaller people who have been a woman their whole
life.
It's not fair.
It's,
it's is as much cheating as taking steroids when the other person doesn't,
or taking performance enhancing drugs when the other person doesn't.
Maybe even more so maybe in more so because you also have,
there's a bunch of advantages in terms of reaction time that males enjoy.
It's like it's some significant difference in reaction time between males and
even untrained males versus female professional athletes.
Well,
uh,
I disagree.
And,
and what do you disagree,
but I've already,
well,
the,
my main point being the one that I already made,
right?
That like I don't think that there is such a thing as a perfectly level playing
field.
I think we decide what kind of playing field we want to have.
Sure.
Make the
distinction where we don't allow men to compete in a women's divisions.
And I think that that distinction may be breaking down a bit.
Right.
And I think it may be time to break down that distinction a little.
So you think that male should be able to compete in the women's division of
weightlifting?
Uh,
no,
I don't necessarily.
Um,
but Ken,
if they transition,
uh,
well first of all,
the,
there's,
there's a lot of stuff to break down,
right?
And I'm not,
I'm not an expert on the subject,
right?
So it's just sort of my off the top of my head.
Um,
one thing is,
you know,
you're postulating a particular person who decided to transition,
uh,
at the age of 30.
Right?
And they were very big and strong before,
right?
And they decided to transition.
Now that is a type of person that exists,
right?
Um,
I think over the next certainly 30 years,
we're going to see,
you know,
uh,
now that,
people are starting to understand that being trans is just a way that people are
right.
There are just people who are trans,
you know,
and this is something that we're going to accept and support,
right?
You're seeing folks,
Tra transition much,
much earlier age,
you know,
um,
uh,
and,
and so if someone is,
if someone is,
you know,
transitioning from the age of like,
seven years old,
right?
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
working with those hormones,
uh,
from that age,
right,
they're not going to have their body's situations can be very different than the
one that you,
that you postulated.
Right.
Uh,
I also know from my trans friends that the,
uh,
the effects that the hormones have on your body are like really profound.
You know,
like really,
really profound.
Like we're not like,
um,
uh,
to a surprising degree.
Right.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
you know,
I have,
look,
if the question is how does,
you know,
how does a person who starts taking hormones at a,
at a particular age,
right?
How does their body change and how's that affect visa vi athletic performance?
I don't know.
We're in such new territory here,
right?
Well,
we certainly are,
and we particularly,
we just scratched upon the idea of kids transitioning at a very early age.
I mean,
there's been more scientific evidence of points that if kids don't do that,
then when they wanted to be trans at an early age,
they just become gay men.
And that there's nothing wrong with that either.
Um,
there's no reason to give kids hormones and there's no reason to decide before a
person's frontal lobe is completely full,
completely fully developed,
which doesn't even take place until the 25 kid.
People don't know who they are.
A seven year old,
you,
you won't even,
people don't even give their seven year old phones.
You don't let them vote.
You're going to let them decide what sex they're going to be for the rest of
their life.
The research that I've seen,
and again,
I'm not an expert on this and yeah,
you know,
I'd love to,
this is a conversation.
This is the thing I'd love to talk about on our show and I'd specifically love,
you know,
this is before does the kind of topic where I really want to make sure that I
know the research and that I'm also speaking to Trans folks,
you know,
um,
in,
in this conversation.
But,
so to touch on just what I've,
you know,
my own experience and what I've,
the research I've seen,
the research I've seen is that trans kids from a young age,
uh,
they are incredibly consistent in there,
you know,
when they're expressing their gender identity,
um,
big jail was in
that and that my,
a lot of human beings,
yeah,
yeah.
But that,
that's,
that's fit.
I'm just narrative by saying they're incredibly consistent.
But like if you polled these people,
like what are you talking about?
Like if you,
I mean that's,
I,
I look,
I don't have the research in front of me that I saw,
so I can't like go into the details on it.
But like,
yeah,
it was,
I mean,
you know,
it was a research that was surveying and tracking like trans kids who declared
their identity from a young age.
Did it change?
The answer was,
uh,
generally,
no,
it really didn't.
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
I have a friend who has a,
who has a trans kid,
um,
don't know the kids exact age,
but you know,
in the age range that we're talking about and you know,
he's explained that like,
well,
you know,
my child from a very young age consistently like said,
I am a girl,
like,
and has never contradicted themselves,
never changed their mind.
And so the humane thing and the thing that he felt was going to do as a parent
was to like,
embrace that choice on his child's part.
Right.
Um,
and yeah,
that's the,
the embrace that choice,
meaning hormonally,
I shouldn't even phrase it as a choice,
like,
like embrace that identity.
Um,
but it is a choice,
right?
I mean,
if I had chosen to add hormones to a child's body,
that's a choice.
Uh,
it's a than the choice on that.
It's,
it's the,
it's a choice on a point on the part of the parent.
Um,
it's not a choice in the,
on the,
uh,
on the part of the child to like,
in the same way that being said with it being gay isn't a choice.
Yeah.
That's who they are.
If they think that they're a girl,
why do you have to give them hormones to make them more of a girl?
Uh,
because,
uh,
I'm sorry,
can you expand on the question?
Simple question.
If you say that the child thinks it's a girl,
so you're going to give the child hormones [inaudible] if the child thinks it's
a girl,
let it be a girl.
Like you don't have,
why are you adding hormones?
If you're shooting hormones into a child and you're affecting the child's
development,
you're saying that's not a choice.
That's nonsense.
Of course.
It's a choice.
You're choosing to chemically change this child's body.
He choosing to inject things into this child's body on a regular basis that are
going to radically affect the physical development of their body.
Yeah.
And you're saying that this isn't a choice.
What's definitely a choice to do that?
So,
so what Trans People Express,
um,
and again,
I'm not an expert.
This is from me talking to my trans friends and,
and you know,
uh,
seeing what other trans folks say is that the experience of being trans and not
receiving hormones,
right?
And not having the body that you identify with,
the feeling of Dysphoria,
right,
is extremely like painful.
Um,
and is a condition unto itself,
right?
Um,
and,
uh,
the,
the feeling of not belonging with the body that you have of that mismatch,
right?
That seems to be in the broad variety of humanity,
the way that some people are born,
right?
Where their inner self,
right.
The self that they are,
they're like,
I am a,
you know,
they're not thinking they are a woman.
They're like,
this is the,
that I am doesn't match the body that they have.
Right.
And that gives them extreme distress,
right?
And that leads to suicide.
That leads to,
uh,
you know,
other damaging behaviors.
Right.
And the best treatment for that that we know exists is to,
uh,
you know,
have,
do gender confirmation via hormones.
Um,
and
that doesn't effect the suicide rate.
The suicide rate for Trans People's very high,
postop and preop really doesn't get affected by whether or not you treat them
well.
The operation,
uh,
you know,
one of the questions conception is why is that?
Is that because they're not accepted by society and we're not more loving?
Could it be underlying issues that are causing them to feel this way in the
first place?
Like what is it we don't know.
And I felt,
I'm sure it varies widely.
It looks,
so I,
all I can do
is,
uh,
defer to the experts that,
that I know about this.
Right.
So,
um,
uh,
you know,
for instance,
there's an author named Bren Tana Hill,
who's a,
uh,
former,
former military helicopter pilot.
I just interviewed her for my new podcast that's coming out soon called
factually.
I'm doing it on Earwolf and it's like a long form interview podcast.
Um,
and so she's one of the people who's affected by,
uh,
the,
Trump,
uh,
military ban on Trans Service people,
you know,
so that's why we brought her home because she's trans.
Yeah.
Um,
and uh,
she wrote a fantastic book called everything you need to know about trans that
like she's a,
she is now a researcher,
right?
And she went into really deep detail about like,
here is all of the medical science here is all of here's all the science about
it.
And so at this point in the conversation,
I would say like,
hey man,
I just got a bone up on,
you know,
on that because I don't want to speak to suicide rates.
My
concern is with children.
My concern is not with young adults deciding to take steps to confirm their
gender identity,
who they feel they really are.
I'm all for you doing whenever you want to do when you're an adult,
when your mind is formed.
But people change their mind.
They change their opinion,
they changed their thoughts.
There's nothing wrong with just deciding to be a gay man.
There's nothing wrong with your body.
Uh,
you know,
as you grow and mature and develop,
you growing out of these ideas,
some wheel in some world and the ones who won't,
they always have the option to do something later on in life.
But if you do something to hormonally block a child valley very early on,
there's no turning back from that.
Well let me say it,
let me say a few things of that.
First of all,
it's not wrong to be concerned about children and there's a reason this is the
most intense part of this conversation and I think it's correct,
right?
Because we're all very concerned about children.
Right?
But I do want to say,
first of all,
I don't think it's correct that trans people,
if they don't receive four months from an,
from a young age,
they simply become gay men.
Because I know it happens very often.
I know trans people,
if you
can find that,
cause it was a big article that was written about that recently where they were
talking about whether or not gender confirmation surgery and hormone blockers on
young children is ethical because of this fact.
And this was what they were talking about,
where people at one point in time wanted to be trans and they listed several
famous examples and then as they became older,
just decided to be gang,
including women who wanted to be men who just became gay women.
And I think,
what's that girl's name that was in John Wick?
Ruby rose.
She was one of those,
she was a trans when she was younger and now she's just a gay woman.
So look,
I,
I know,
I know quite a few,
uh,
trans folks.
Right?
Um,
and I have to be honest,
none of the ones that I know,
we're,
I don't know any trans women personally who are gay men up until they
transitioned.
Right.
I know quite a few trans women who are straight men.
Um,
or who,
you know,
lived their lives as to present it as straight men.
Right.
And then transitioned.
Um,
as an order come lesbians.
Uh,
yeah,
I mean that's,
that's one of the ways that people can be,
I really recommend that.
Um,
oh,
the other thing I was going to say is that I do know also among the Trans folks
that I know where the Trans people who speak about this,
that I've heard so many of them say,
I wish I had access.
I knew this about myself at a very young age and I wish to God that I had,
that we had,
I had had the ability to receive these hormones at a young age.
My life would be so much better.
And I'm not gonna Argue with those folks.
You know,
I wouldn't know
these folks either.
But you have to address the fact that there are people that have gone through
transition surgery and said,
I wish to God that I never did this.
There's a lot of those people too.
So if you're looking for anecdotal evidence and you want to be objective,
you kind of have,
I'm sure we can.
I'm sure we can find the anecdotes.
Um,
I'm very curious and this is what I'd go consult my friend,
uh,
or my recent interview,
such a brand hit Tana hills,
uh,
work on this to see how many,
how many are in each group.
Right.
And uh,
which,
which sets of these folks are the outliers.
I think the folks that you're talking about are probably the outliers,
but I can't confirm that.
All sir,
juries have potential costs.
However,
according to a Swedish study of 324 patients,
three 40,
1% of whom were born female surgery was associated with considerably higher risk
for mortality,
suicidal behavior and psychiatric morbidity than the general population.
So that's people who got the surgery.
I am curious,
wait,
3.4,
1% of them.
I mean the d the devil of this is in the details,
right?
Because how much is the,
is the higher risk,
what does it mean?
3.1% of those who were born female,
well,
some of them were born female and the other ones were born male.
The males that transition to females is what it's saying.
It's only saying a small percentage of them were born female that transitioned
to male,
but the larger percentage was males who transitioned to female.
And that the surgery that they received was associated with considerably higher
risks for mortality,
suicidal behavior and psychiatric morbidity than the general population that's
not healing them.
That's saying that having that surgeries associated with higher risk of
mortality,
suicidal behavior and psychiatric morbidity.
But it also says above following surgery,
patients report lower gender dysphoria and improved sexual relationships right
before they killed themselves.
Everything's awesome.
Well,
this isn't saying that people are killing themselves.
You know,
you're looking for,
you're looking for something that confirms established opinion you and as are
you,
you know,
I mean we're,
we're,
we're looking at this and just look,
it should be,
we should be,
we should always be careful of drawing too much from,
you know,
a single study and like look at it widely.
Right.
Um,
but,
uh,
what was the point I was about to make?
Um,
it flipped my head.
Uh,
I,
I'm sort of at the,
Oh,
here's what it was.
Um,
surgery.
Another thing I know from,
from speaking to the Trans folks is that surgery is overemphasized,
right?
And then,
and that surgery for those folks is not the,
you know,
we as sort of straight CIS people tend to put too much emphasis on like,
oh,
did you get the surgery yet?
Or not?
You know,
and really it's more about what are you living as and what is,
you know,
what sort of set of hormones do you have?
Right.
Um,
but I,
I would really,
uh,
one of the,
I've sort of reached the limit of like my facility with this topic.
I really want to shout out,
um,
uh,
videos made by a friend of mine.
Her videos are called Contra points.
Her name's Natalie when,
and she does these increase.
She's a former,
a philosopher,
former philosophy phd,
and she does these incredibly funny videos about,
is not just about transitions,
about all types of things.
Um,
uh,
she had a really great one about comedy recently,
um,
but she really breaks down like a lot of these,
uh,
a lot of misconceptions,
right.
And has really changed every time I watch.
One of her videos.
I'm like learning new things and new ideas are like pop,
pop,
pop in my head,
you know.
Um,
and I,
I think you should check them out and you might enjoy talking to her on the,
on the show.
She's like a really fascinating person.
Contra points.
It's an incredibly complex subject really.
It had a really is fuck
angel on the podcast before who transitioned from female to male,
which is also a different and interesting thing.
Um,
you know,
and he said that his whole life just felt like he was a boy and he didn't
understand why he didn't have a penis.
He didn't understand like the whole,
it didn't make sense.
And then once he transitioned to being a male,
then he felt complete.
I don't deny that.
My entire concern is that you're making decisions for children and that this is
a completely new thing with no historical precedent.
We've never done this before.
There's not like a history of hundreds of years of hormone blocker is being used
on young children and whether or not that is healthy and promotes a positive
life.
I feel like if a child thinks there are girl,
let them live as a girl,
but you don't have to hormonally engage with their body with chemicals.
It just seems crazy.
It seems ill advised.
It does.
It seems like this movement of acceptance and progressive thinking in in in many
ways is a fantastic thing.
It's a fantastic movement,
but this seems to me to be a leap and that you're making this leap to confirm
your ideology and to confirm that you know,
you're 100% cool with trans people and you're 100% cool and you,
you're going to recognize this child is trans,
but you're doing something.
You're,
you're doing something to this child's body that you can't turn around.
And if this child decides at whatever age we decide that you can make rational
decisions to transition as trans,
let them fully develop first.
Let them be a person,
let them make these decisions.
But if you want identify as a woman you and you want to keep your penis,
that should be fine too.
There's nothing wrong with that.
If you want to keep a functional penis,
you want to identify as a woman and not even take hormones.
Who Cares?
Do that,
do that.
But when you're stepping in to a developing baby that's only been alive for six
years and you're shooting chemicals into its body to change the way it develops,
show me the research.
Show me the decades of peer reviewed studies on one of the most important things
that we know of the development of a human being where you're going to home more
hormonally,
interact with their body in some sort of a random doctor,
Frankenstein sort of way,
like how much but what evidence do we know?
What evidence do we have that this is a a powerful,
absolute like intelligent,
smart way to handle a child's life over the long term.
Like when these kids grow to be 60 as opposed to kids who don't get the hormone
shots when they're six,
these people are 15% more happy.
There's nothing like that,
but yet people are jumping into it because it seems like the thing to do because
it seems like the tide of society is moving in that
direction.
Well,
I,
I don't jump into it for that reason.
Um,
I do think that when we're talking about an issue that affects those people,
right?
The first thing we should do is listen to those people,
So the children listen to the children and listen to the adults,
right.
Who said,
I used to be that child.
Okay.
But they are
that child.
And you know,
to you said,
look,
everyone's different.
So for them to say,
I was that child,
that's nonsense.
You were a similar child in a similar situation.
We're not that China.
They're not literally,
but they don't know how that child is feeling.
They don't know how much that child is being influenced by its environment.
They don't know how much their thoughts and their expressions are being
encouraged by their parents.
They don't know that child.
Sure.
So my point is,
when we're taught,
when you and I are talking about this right now,
we're speaking pretty hypothetically,
right?
We're,
we're talking about a child that is not in the room that we don't have.
We're talking about a fictional child.
Right.
So what we really care about are the actual people.
Um,
and when we talk to the actual trans folks,
right.
And,
uh,
talk to,
you know,
say,
Hey,
what do you think?
You know,
how do you feel?
And,
uh,
you know,
include them in the conversation.
I think we have a different conversation about it.
You know,
we do have an conversation,
but we also have a different conversation.
We talked to people that have regret from transition surgery cause there's a lot
of those.
Sure.
But we're not,
we don't have either of those folks in the room.
Right.
You know,
we have to acknowledge that they're real as well.
Yeah.
I don't,
uh,
I'm not,
I'm not dismissing that those people are real.
Say if you talk to Trans folks,
you get this impression.
That's not necessarily true.
Um,
a wide range of impressions.
I wasn't just,
I wasn't talking about specifically the impression that I wasn't saying we
should reason from anecdotal evidence.
Right.
I'm saying that,
um,
look,
the last conversation I had with a person about this was a,
uh,
was a trans military veteran who is a researcher who wrote a book on,
on these issues,
right.
Comprehensively looked at the research and told me that the research shows that
the evidence that you're asking for exists maybe not on a 30 year timeline,
but there have been studies of this in here's what we know about them,
right.
About Children's.
Uh,
uh,
yeah.
I mean that's,
that is my understanding of the reason I have not looked at the research myself.
And you know,
I have not done the topic on my shows,
the positive benefits of children transitioning.
I don't think that exists.
Well,
we can't solve that in this conversation right here.
Um,
but,
uh,
so my point is,
look,
I'm not going to go out on a limb and tell you more than I can.
I can say off the top of my head,
right,
because I'm not an expert on the subject.
Uh,
this is something that,
you know,
if I,
if this were something we had done on our show and I had doubt dive into the
research more,
I could tell you more.
I know it exists,
but I can tell you what I have been told exists by people who have made it their
business to know,
you know.
Um,
so,
uh,
you know,
that would be my next step in the conversation.
Um,
uh,
but,
you know,
that's what I'm saying is,
uh,
those are including those folks in this conversation is a really critical part
of it for me.
Um,
so yeah.
Uh,
what's a conversation in the world needs to have for sure.
Yeah.
And I think it's one that we will have and you know,
again,
just to bring it back to athletics,
right?
Um,
I think that the,
uh,
undeniable existence of trans children to teenagers to adults,
right.
Who want to compete.
Right.
Um,
and who make a compelling case to that,
that they should be able to compete,
right.
Um,
is going to be selling that we're going to have to grapple with.
You know,
I think there's going to be easy answers to it.
Um,
and yeah,
I mean,
I think the real,
the legitimate solution is a trans leak or a trans division to have a male
division of female division of Trans Division if you want to compete
athletically.
That's fair to me.
That makes sense.
Well,
I hope that there's,
you know,
like say with the,
you've got the pair Olympics and the Paralympics is really like,
it's divided you,
you know how they do it,
where they do like all the different levels for you've got this much amputated
or you're this mobile and you can compete in this way,
you know?
And so that's really great to make a way that,
you know,
those folks can compete on a level as a playing fields.
We can be given the,
the manifold variations in human bodies.
Right.
But the fact that I,
Oscar Pistorius,
which by the way,
we should bring up the gun.
He killed his girlfriend,
which is a very weird part of the story.
And he said he thought she was a robber bazaar.
Completely bizarre.
But the fact that he was able to compete in the Olympics,
right,
not just in the Paralympics.
I think it's such a wonderful thing,
you know,
and so I would hope that whatever organization we come up with,
allows for the,
uh,
allows for humans and all their variations to compete in the Maine League as
well.
Right.
Because it's fair as possible.
They come up with bionic legs like Steve Austin from the $6 million man.
There's some people out there that will cut their fucking legs off to run
faster.
And that's real.
There are people that want to win so bad they would cut the bottom of their legs
off to get bionic prosthesis.
They wasn't really for sure.
100% would,
would you?
No,
I wouldn't,
but I'm not crazy.
Look this people that raise their hands just cause they,
they,
they're,
they are a bit,
do you know that people have that feeling that they're supposed to be disabled
so they amputated their hands?
Yes.
This people with all sorts of psychological disorders,
but the need to win is so insanely strong in some people.
And if they found out that,
hey man,
well who gives a fuck about your feet and your calves,
man,
they're going to look just like feet and calves,
except they allow you to run 45 miles an hour.
But don't think people would do it.
Isn't that a little similar to the idea
where people say,
oh,
trans bathrooms,
it's just so men are just going to lie about us.
They can go in the bathroom and peep at women.
And then when you actually expand that,
right,
and you're like,
hold on a second,
you're telling me a dude is going to tell the entire world I am.
I am not an aunt.
I'm a woman.
They're gonna start dressing differently.
They're going to take hormones.
They're going to like live with the stigma,
right?
They're going to one of the most stigmatized type of people you can be in
America today was a trans person and they're going to live with that stigma.
They're gonna change our whole lives.
And they're going to do all of that just so they can peep at women in the
bathroom.
It doesn't make any sense.
Highly Unlikely.
And it doesn't make any sense,
but it also,
that's not entirely what could happen.
The,
what also could happen is you could get some creep who dresses up like a woman
and goes to the mail to the women's bathroom.
You can get that.
I mean,
I'm all for Trans People.
Listen,
but you can't have it now.
I'm all for it.
But if you have a bathroom that allows trans people and you get some creep who
says,
I'm just going to pretend to be trans.
If you don't think that's real,
then you're crazy.
Of course people do that.
Of course there's,
and people if arrested,
no,
there is,
there's people who have been arrested,
men who were sex offenders who dressed up as women and went into the women's
room and harassed women.
There's already been a wrists.
This is,
but it's not.
But at least when they happen to be trans,
but here's the thing,
they're not trans people and people that are taking advantage of a loophole and
their creeps and they,
they probably want it to go into the female bathroom anyway,
but they just couldn't do it before.
And now that there's trans exclusive inclusive bathrooms,
some creeps have been arrested doing that.
They're not trans people.
The real problem is the creeps.
The real problem is not the Trans people using the women's room.
They should of course be able to use the women's room,
but the creeps can go like you don't need a law firm like it.
So if they're not trans people,
right,
they are not supposed to be in the bathroom right there from the same way trans
people and this is what people were worried about,
but they have arrested people doing that,
but so they could also do that even if it was not a gender inclusive bathroom
because there would be breaking the rules of the bathroom and exactly the same
way
making the bathroom man and address versus them being trans.
See,
if you see a trans person,
oftentimes tramps.
People look very masculine.
There's no need.
If you're just going to pretend to be trans,
there's no need to hide what you have to ask address.
All you have to ask ourselves is if the hypothetical or if the extremely,
extremely rare situation that you're discussing right,
is so horrifying to us and such a,
uh,
such a big problem that it's worth disenfranchising millions of people from the
ability to simply go to the bathroom when they need to,
you know,
if,
if that extreme edge case or hypothetical case,
right,
are we really going to,
uh,
you know,
hurt all,
all of these actual people who actually exist and say,
hey,
I just need to Goddamn go to the bathroom,
you know,
um,
in a,
in a place that is,
uh,
you know,
safe for me.
Right.
Um,
and I don't think,
I don't think it is,
you know,
like we,
we can talk about that one edge case all day long,
but the end of the day,
it's been more than one case.
But I think,
here's the question,
what were,
what are there more of,
are there more trans people or they're more sexual predators?
100% more trans people than sexual predators who are specifically going to put
on a dress.
And in order to go into a bathroom specifically.
Yeah,
100%.
There's more trans people like by a factor of a million.
Well I don't know how many people are trans.
Uh,
what's the numbers on that?
You know,
I don't know.
But I would,
I would consult my,
a consultant,
my friend Brian's book to find out,
because I'm sure it's in,
I guess she,
she wrote a book that breaks down all of these statistics called everything you
need to know about trading mine field of a subject.
You know,
as soon as you start bringing this shit up,
people go crazy cause it's,
uh,
it's complicated and people,
they dig their heels in the ground,
in both sides,
you know,
and,
I,
I tried to have,
I'm happy we're able to have a conversation about it.
I try to have a conversation that's based on,
you know,
what,
I try not to say more than I than I think I can say,
uh,
with,
you know,
with surety.
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
but my basic principle is,
man,
I just want to defer to the humanity of the people that I'm talking about.
You know what I mean?
And rather than say,
oh,
well here's my idea,
here's my concern.
What about though?
What if,
uh,
you know,
what,
what if a,
a space alien were to come down to x,
Y,
z?
You know what I mean?
Rather than trying to come up with thought experiments about it,
you know,
it was like,
hey,
there's some people in America,
they're making a polite request.
Can we use the bathroom?
Please go ahead.
You know,
that's,
that's my,
that's what I default to write.
Or just killed it forever.
And if they kill the performance and you don't have any issues,
I think there's a way with sports again,
right?
I genuinely think,
hey my,
my default is I understand his problem.
I understand you're going to have female athletes who,
who are,
who say,
Hey,
wait a second,
is this fair?
Right.
I think we can go forward with good faith and find a way.
Let's find a model that works for everybody.
You know,
I think we can do it in a way that respects the humanity of the trans athletes
and assists athletes.
I think that we can do that.
Um,
and that's the,
that will always be mine.
It's easy to say as an outsider,
if you're a female athletes,
it's been forced to compete with trans women who used to be men for most of
their lives.
I think you'd have a different opinion because I think they have a distinct
physiological advantage that's been expressed many times.
I mean,
it's,
there's just a lot of records have been broken by Trans women who are now
weightlifters and there's that one who's the fucking dirt biker,
who's was a professional dirt bike professional rider before as a man and then
transitioned over to a woman.
It's just dominating these things.
It's just,
I don't necessarily think it's fair.
I think just like,
it's not fair for a man to compete as a woman.
I don't think that all those disadvantages or those advantages rather go away
when you transition,
especially in a short time period.
I just don't think they do.
And I don't think there's any evidence that shows they do,
there's a diminishing amount,
but how much so,
and in fact,
there's a doctor,
a board certified endocrinologist,
Dr Ramona Crut sick I think is her name.
We did a whole article on this about fighters,
about male fighters,
uh,
transitioning to becoming female and competing as female,
which has happened.
And they're saying that not only does the estrogen therapy,
uh,
it actually preserves bone density.
It doesn't just turn them into a woman or turn them into female or so their
hormonal profiles similar to females,
but also preserves their masculine bone density.
Because one of the reasons why women lose bone density as they get older is a
lack of estrogen.
That's part of the reason why I asked her.
A process kicks in that that stops it in its tracks when you're,
you're injecting,
um,
female hormones into a male's frame.
So they maintain this male bone density.
Now there's also arguments that African American female bone density is on,
in many cases,
similar to a white European male bone density.
So that's the,
um,
the argument about the outliers and about whether or not it's a level playing
field because it most certainly is.
Yeah.
I mean,
so that,
that's where I get back to the idea that,
look,
could someone show that a athlete who a trans athlete who wants to compete is
going to have a physiological advantage because of their history of transition.
Right?
Could that be the case?
Sometimes.
Probably so.
You know,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna argue that.
Well,
let's,
how about this,
because I actually don't want to know one way or the other because I have not
looked at any research on this,
so I don't wanna make any claim.
Um,
so let's just,
let's just grant that for the sake of this thought experiment.
Right.
Okay.
Um,
so that being said,
let's compare that against every single other advantage that every other
competitor could have.
Socioeconomic advantage,
right.
Country of origin.
Um,
you know,
whether or not they live in Denver,
if they live below sea level,
you know,
like all those different things.
Right.
Um,
do is it humane to draw a line around that one unearned advantage,
right?
Uh,
against all those other honor and advantages,
you know,
at what point does our,
uh,
fantasy of having a level of having a true level playing field end up hurting,
you know,
end up,
end up excluding people.
And that's the conversation that I think we could have.
You know,
I,
I heard a really great,
this is just the beginning of a thought,
right?
Um,
but,
um,
it came up,
so just somewhere I was talking to,
um,
uh,
some people about this,
and in sports,
one of the things,
our assumption that men have an advantage over women,
right?
In sports,
in sports.
Yeah.
Our assumption.
Well,
yeah,
let me,
let me expand on our assumption that men have an advantage over women in sports,
um,
is partially based on the fact that so many of the sports were designed for male
bodies,
right?
They're optimized for male bodies,
Basketball for example.
Right.
Um,
uh,
you know,
was an optimized for mailbox.
It's like the,
uh,
the,
the height of the basket.
You know,
the,
um,
uh,
the way that the ball moves around,
you know,
like,
like if we were at ball moves,
if we're going to say that,
if we're going to say that men and women have physiological differences,
right?
And then we're creating sports and the sports are sort of tuned to the
physiological differences.
We're splitting hairs here.
We're talking about power,
speed,
athleticism,
all those.
There's an advantage of that
when you look at say gymnastics,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
I would say that like women for the events that are in a women's gymnastic
competition,
right?
Having an advantage over men,
Women don't,
women don't compete on the ring hold thing.
You know what I'm in.
Right?
Uh,
men don't compete at,
at some of that crazy,
uh,
you know,
bar shit.
You know what I mean?
Like it larger there,
it's its height,
its flexibility.
It's like there's a lot going on,
right?
So that's a rare case where Ge women's gymnastics,
we've actually created events in that and like competitions that like only women
can do.
Right.
Um,
and so we sort of optimize that sport more for a female body.
Right.
What if we did that with a lot more sports.
Um,
and how about this?
What if we were able to develop,
cause again the rules of the game,
right,
are not absolute.
The rules of the game are things that humans create.
Right.
And so why do we like maybe part of our assumption that men are better at sports
than women or men have an advantage of sports and women are that we have
constructed,
most of the Games that we've constructed are actually sort of biased towards a
male type of body.
That sounds ridiculous.
First of all.
And reason why gymnastics is like why women are good at gymnastics,
first of all,
their,
their flexibility,
their lightness,
all those things.
Also they're not competing against men in a one on one type of situation.
Like one's trying to defend the other one's trying to attack like a game of
basketball or a game of football or any other sort of team sport with any male
gymnast and trying to have them compete against the jets.
That's not going to be a little those things.
It's a physical event as opposed to a sport.
So a physical event is you have to do this thing.
It's very athletic.
It's an athletic endeavor.
Sure do it as a balance.
You land.
No one's trying to stop you from doing it again.
When you're shooting basketballs,
you're not just shooting basketballs.
You're trying to shoot a basketball,
what people were trying to defend.
You're trying to Juke left and then go right.
You're trying to be sneaky.
You're trying to shoot from the outside.
There's all this shit going on in.
A lot of,
it involves your ability to move fast,
to close distance,
to have the physical strength,
the leap up in the air,
and there's a huge physical advantage that men enjoy and this is not because the
sports designed this way.
It's because the support is very simple.
There's a basket on one side of basket on the other side.
You got to get it in here.
They got to get it in there.
Ready,
go.
If you're faster and your stronger,
you'll be able to accomplish that better.
Males are faster and stronger.
There's a reason why there's a male and a female division.
It's not that these sports were designed for males is that men are physically
bigger and stronger and faster than this.
These are physiological advantages.
Yeah.
You can have a thing like a gymnastics balance beam event where women are going
to shine because they're lighter and more flexible and they can do things with
their body that men can't because of the shape of them.
All the mass,
all the different things.
But that's rare.
That's the outlier.
I,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't think we actually disagree that much.
Um,
the reason it's rare
is because historically we've created most of our sports around things that men
have the advantage,
and you're,
you're not wrong.
Boards are,
most sports involves speed and power,
most ports,
but why men have an advantage in speed and power.
I know,
but we created those sports,
right?
Like what would we possibly be able to create where women would have an
advantage that is an athletic event where a man speed and power does not give
him an advantage.
I'm in La,
look,
man,
this,
this is not,
again,
like I said,
this is the beginning of a thought,
right?
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to use this as a thought experiment as sort of like a,
a possibility opening device.
Right?
Right.
But so you,
you postulate,
hey,
now you,
you make a fair point that there's a difference between individual athletic
events like gymnastics and competitive one-on-one or events like,
you know,
grappling or,
or basketball or something like that.
Right?
And so,
um,
and again,
I'm thinking this through myself as I'm talking about it,
right?
But,
um,
like I don't think it's impossible that you could come up with a one on one
competition that,
uh,
privileges that that is,
that is designed around the same athletic qualities that make a women make a
woman,
uh,
give her an advantage in a certain gymnastics event.
I don't think there's any reason you couldn't do the same thing for a find a one
on one competition that did the same thing.
Right?
Um,
there's also,
uh,
what could it be a,
I mean,
well,
here's an example.
Uh,
for instance,
uh,
I believe,
I'm not sure,
I'm not 100% sure,
but I believe in like shooting events,
right?
Uh,
for example,
that women and men are on a level playing field.
Correct.
Or,
or that,
uh,
like,
you know,
sort of air rifle sort of thing.
Um,
that like there are events,
right?
Uh,
there,
there do exist athletic where,
uh,
you can have men and women in direct competition with each other,
right.
Where that,
where that event is not designed around a particular facet of a,
you know,
male or female body.
Right.
Um,
so,
uh,
my point is,
look,
men,
have we you,
do you agree that men have run the country in the world for like most of
civilization?
Like most every country.
Okay,
great.
So men have been the ones setting up the sports.
So the fact that as you say,
it's rare that we have sports that are sort of more designed around a female,
you know,
the differences between women as opposed to men.
Right.
I think that might be because men had been setting up all the sports.
And so my,
so my point is sports that women gravitate towards.
How do you mean there's sports that women gravitate towards that they really
enjoy this,
like women's volleyball.
She a witch,
right?
Oh No,
there's many women have traditionally gravitated towards gymnastics as you said
earlier,
is the example.
But those are way more women involved in gymnastics and men.
Oh,
absolutely.
Um,
but there,
those are the sports that get the less attention.
Right now we have less huge amounts.
It sure does.
It's one of the rare examples of like ones where,
you know,
that is a real female forward,
female first sport,
right?
No one bothers me the most is the volleyball.
Why's that?
Because the girls have to dress like hoes,
like even in the Olympics that were thongs.
I fucking basketball players and address like that.
Yeah,
that's fucked up man.
They can choose what they're wearing.
I think.
What's her name?
The Muslim Egyptian team.
They dress in national guard.
What's the name of the volleyball player who has a,
has the black tape on?
Um,
very famous.
You know,
the,
the two,
the two women,
the two women from the u s they're very famous volleyball players.
Whose names I can't remember.
They probably aren't complaining about what they're wearing.
They're probably choosing what they're wearing.
I don't know.
Um,
I don't think anyone is forced them to wear that stuff,
but I mean,
when I tune into a Olympic volleyball,
my Tim like these girls in their underwear pretending they're at the beach,
they're not even at the beach.
It's a choice.
Apparently they want it to where they want to wear it.
Good move.
But is that a choice for the men?
Basketball players?
Can they wear thongs?
They can wear short shorts.
If they decided where they,
they could wear it like a,
a cut off with a midriff showing and a and a little booty shorts.
They might be allowed to,
if they wanted to speak it back to CBS in their masculinity,
they might get shit in the locker room,
you know what I mean?
But maybe they make a point.
I like the short shorts that they used to wear a couple of decades ago,
so,
okay,
look,
yeah,
Larry Bird style.
You know,
one of the things I love about baseball and I started watching baseball is a,
you get to choose your own baseball pants.
He ever noticed that,
like they get to choose.
When you look at them.
Some of them were really tight baseball pants and then someone wear really baggy
baseball pants and I just love imagining,
I like clothes.
I imagine them going to like the baseball Taylor and being like,
dude I want to like sag my pants.
I want to,
you know,
show a little swag.
But you don't want to impede your performance.
So I think the tight would be better as you're running swimmers shape their
bodies to be more aerodynamic.
I mean how much really if you're just running to first base,
how much does like baggy pants?
The wind,
the baggy pants.
Okay.
That is a real will you look at like Manny Ramirez had like the baggy his pants.
I remember and like you had to imagine that guy was like a little bit suboptimal
with his baseball pants.
You know,
maybe cause he was at like
and stuff.
Yeah.
Maybe had big ass thighs and the only feel good with the baggy pants.
Let me just put a bow on on what I was trying to get earlier.
Right.
Cause I know I was,
I was sort of like getting to a pretty spacey place.
Um,
my point is just what our show is about so much is about showing how the things
that we take for granted in our world,
like the way the world is so much of the time is just something that we built.
Right,
right.
And we can question it.
And so when we say men are men have evangelists in women over sports,
I'm like,
well,
hold on a second.
Let's look at how we set the sports up and is it possible that we could set up,
set it up in a different way,
right.
That would allow more people to compete in sports.
Right?
It might not be the same sports.
I'm not going to say that women should play in the NFL against men.
Right.
I don't think it would be safe.
I don't think anyone should play in the NFL.
Frankly.
I think it's way too dangerous.
Uh,
it's very bad for people.
But um,
uh,
is it like,
is our assumption just based on,
Hey,
these are the sports that we invented.
We happened to invent sports that were men have the advantage.
Can we imagine a world where 90% of sports are ones where women have an
advantage of would we be having a different conversation?
And if that's the case,
could we come up with some sports that like everybody,
you know that where there's no,
uh,
does it
nonphysical sports?
I think.
Um,
but I think yeah,
you could come out with competitions were women and female,
traditional female characteristics would have an advantage for sure.
You could,
I mean,
it could definitely be done,
you know,
it's just the ones that exist now when that involve running and lifting things
and moving fast physical lot physiologically males have an advantage.
Yeah.
That's why we have these distinctions and went to,
while we have men's divisions and women's divisions over hundreds and hundreds
of years ago.
You know what,
that's just not fair.
It's not fair,
you know?
But you know,
I mean,
it,
is,
it the like that's the,
that's the notion of fairness we have now.
And you know,
I think the interesting thing about the question trans athletes is it's going to
challenge that notion.
It's going to lead to conversations like this one.
You know,
I think that's really cool and that's what I think we're sort of,
we should be down to have as a society,
right?
You're talking about things,
especially when there's a disagreement is the only way to solve them.
But you know,
I think these conversations oftentimes become these shouting matches and I,
you know,
everybody digs their heels in and as you were talking about before about how
people's identities get really locked into ideas that they've held strong to,
whether it's,
um,
I did an identities about religion or identities about politics,
right?
I mean,
that's why when you were talking about Alphas and Betas,
people like,
why is this show getting political?
This is how Dorky people get.
There's nothing political about that.
But you think it's political because it,
it represents these rigid ideology.
Exactly.
It did,
it,
it was,
we stumbled across something that was like a really deep,
this men's rights activist types.
And then they connect that to their,
to their national politics and their sex,
gender,
politics and everything.
And,
and it was just like,
just the idea of questioning that really them off.
Right.
But what I'm about is questioning all these things,
you know,
this conversation that we had,
this disagreement to the extent that we were disagreeing,
um,
I think is a really good one to have.
You know,
and I'm always testing what I think I know and trying to sort of undermine it
and say like,
do I know this for sure.
I mean,
dude,
on our show,
we have done more than one segment.
We have another one coming out later this year where we like go back and we
correct our own mistakes.
We correct the things that we've done wrong on our show.
What was a big one?
Um,
let's see.
A really big one,
uh,
that we have a coming out.
Um,
I'll give you a preview.
we did one about,
uh,
there was,
we did a topic about sugar and fat about how,
you know,
Americans are like obsessed with,
uh,
cutting fat,
the low fat craze.
Right?
Um,
and a lot of that was,
uh,
there,
there was an early research,
there's early research,
uh,
by this one researcher who showed that a sugar costs a lot of heart disease,
you know,
and obesity and stuff like that.
Um,
and the,
uh,
basically the sugar lobby shut him down,
you know,
um,
and uh,
you know,
uh,
we're sort of funding research that really showed that that was the problem and
that research,
uh,
sort of took over and that really led to the sort of anti-fat craze.
Right.
We did a story on that topic.
Um,
we later found out that like,
sort of the way that we had characterized the story of that happening was not a
accurate,
you know,
was or,
or does that make sense?
Like the,
the narrative part of it,
like it's true this guy's research existed.
Right?
Right.
Um,
it's true that the sugar lobby hated it,
you know,
but the research that showed that fat is bad,
that fat causes heart disease as well.
It wasn't like totally shitty research and like this sort of narrative isn't the
only reason that that other research fell out of favor.
Does that make sense?
And so,
uh,
we talked about that as a way that leg,
the story of there was this good guy researcher who is sort of like stifled by
the bad guy researcher in the lobby,
a sort of misled us down that down that path.
It's more complicated than that.
Exactly.
And that's what happens when you're doing a show that has,
you know,
six minute segments,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
That's what I was getting at.
It's like,
well,
when we were talking about earlier,
like the times constraints on some subjects,
like think about how much time we spent just talked about Trans people and Trans
athletes,
maybe an hour at least to cis males talking about something.
You have no personal experience.
And that's one of the reasons we've wanted to do that topic on the show.
But we're like,
man,
we really want to do justice to it and it's really hard to do in six minutes.
I'm looking to go longer in my,
in my career.
I'm looking to find ways to go longer.
Well,
why can't you do it online?
Like,
like say it,
that NCAA thing doesn't pay as well contract,
but do you have a clause in your contract to take some issues that you would
like to talk about and like that the,
the network wouldn't let you talk about,
look,
Ncaa couldn't you do like your own version of it?
Yeah,
totally.
I mean,
I,
I'd have to find a way to fund it,
you know,
definitely not.
Adam ruins everything.
I totally,
totally get that show.
I mean,
so far I've talked about it here.
Right?
Um,
and uh,
I I do want to say,
by the way we talk about the,
the thing that we have a very cool network.
They,
that was the one time they ever called the topic.
And what they did allow us to do was in an episode we have coming out later this
year,
we talk about on the show the fact that they killed that topic and we,
we talked about how as you know,
we're on advertising supported TV and occasionally we,
we tear into advertisers,
you know,
and occasionally we have to have a conversation with the network or the network
says,
ah,
actually Gatorade kind of sponsors the network and you're talking about Gatorade
and then we have to have a conversation.
We still didn't get it did our Gatorade topic,
but we had to like have a talker too and know sugary sports drinks,
we talk,
we said okay,
all of the sports drinks overemphasize,
hydration as a problem,
you know.
Um,
uh,
and so we,
you know,
we did a whole segment examining how much does advertising effect the show.
Right.
And,
and as a result of the NCAA,
we had to kill that segment and the network let us say that on TV.
So that was really,
that was really cool.
Then they allowed us to like bring up that conflict on the show.
But yeah,
no,
there's nothing stopping me from going on the Internet.
It's just,
it just so happens that,
you know,
I'm a comic and,
uh,
you know,
I had the wonderful opportunity.
I've always wanted to have my own TV show.
I had the wonderful opportunity to create one.
If I hadn't had that chance four or five years ago,
I would have,
I would probably be on youtube right now doing like,
you know,
hour long explainer videos with me doing jokes straight to camera.
And I love folks who do that,
like,
uh,
and you know,
maybe I'll,
maybe I'll find myself doing that again someday.
But right now I'm just like too busy making,
it's hard enough doing 16 episodes a TV a year to like also figured out how to
write and research or thing that straight to camera.
But you can only imagine.
And you,
you did start out doing that,
right?
You started out on Youtube.
Yeah,
in college humor.
We,
uh,
I was a writer there and I developed a Adam ruins everything while I was there.
And then we sold it to true TV.
I will say on my,
on my live shows now,
um,
I,
I've just been on tour with my new show mind parasites,
which is like me trying to figure out how,
what I do,
how to do what I do in a standup context,
right.
And so,
uh,
I took that all across the country.
I'm hoping to set up some more dates soon.
Um,
it's this really cool show about how these biological parasites that control
like their hosts,
minds,
like this fungus that takes control of an aunt and like,
um,
uh,
let's see,
a lot,
a lot of weird things.
Like,
it's like literally their minds become controlling this parasite that infects
them and they use that as a way to talk about,
I use that as a way to talk about the cultural parasites that are controlling
our minds,
like advertising,
like,
uh,
the social media algorithm like alcohol.
In my case,
I,
I quit drinking recently.
How long ago?
Uh,
about a year ago.
no,
not at all.
Not at all.
Not at all man.
I'm sorry.
I'm really sorry.
I know you'd love to get me in a Musk moments and a show me
a lot less news.
Very happy not drinking.
I lost a ton of weight right away.
Well yeah,
I'll call is bad for you.
Uh,
but yeah,
so that's,
that show is me going longer.
Right?
And,
and I'm up on stage for like a theme.
It's a theme.
Yeah.
It's like got a title.
It's got a,
it's got sections and I'm right here.
It has a theme like in initially as you like have a framework for it.
Yeah.
Did I did and that was so hard to write because as a comic you're used to going
up and just like,
well I'm just going to riff on a new idea.
Oh that's a chunk.
And then I'll combine it with that other chunk and then that's my special.
Right.
But I was like,
Hey,
I want to figure out a way to do what I do,
which is like come up with a,
an argument and a and some information and put it in a framework.
So I was like,
all right,
mind parasites,
I'll talk about these biological parasites.
I also want to go buy advertising time to write some jokes.
And that was hard as hell to do it.
Felt like doing it backwards.
But I worked it out a lot on stage and,
and eventually founded.
And the show's really a really clicking now.
I'm really a hardship
PNR.
We're just talking about that cause Arusha fear is doing that with his most
recent hour.
Who's his most recent recent hours?
Entirely about his,
uh,
history,
in Orthodox Judaism.
Like he was a serious orthodox Jews spend a lot of time and uh,
in Israel,
like living in one of those religious commune type deals,
what do they call those rich yeshivas?
Oh yeah.
What they call it anyway.
Yeah,
I think,
yeah,
I think that's what it's called.
I mean,
he studied the Talmud and the tour.
I studied it all day long.
No,
that,
yeah.
I mean he's with 12 hours a day and then said this is nonsense.
The fuck am I doing?
And then became Ari.
And so his most recent special that he's in the middle of creating right now is
called Jew.
And it's the first time that he's ever done a total special from top to bottom
on one subject.
And he's piecing it together like a sort of,
in many ways it was influenced by some of the hours that he saw when he went to
Edinburgh.
Yeah.
And a saw the festival,
but he'd said that he wanted to do it American style,
whereas they had these themes but they didn't necessarily emphasize the
punchlines and the standup and the left
I that's the same problem.
I,
that's the same problem I had because when you're writing that way,
you need to make a point and it's often hard.
Like you're like,
all right,
that joke was pretty good,
but I need,
I could juice it more,
but I need to get to the next point,
you know?
And so that's a challenge with writing that way.
But I've just been doing it enough on stage that I've been able to like you,
you know,
like it's,
it's,
look,
I'm not going to say I'm the funniest guy on the planet and funniest
motherfucker ever,
but like,
it's got the punchlines I wanted to have,
you know?
That's awesome.
Yeah,
it's cool.
The thing about it that way too,
as a framework and then start from there.
I know Chris Titus does it that way too.
A lot of guys do it that way where they'll,
they'll try to make a framework and then have all their ideas fit inside of that
frame.
Yeah.
I mean,
the,
the thing that I found out is the reason people ask me how I got into this,
you know,
and I was just a comic in New York,
just going up on stage.
And you know,
after awhile you learn how to make people laugh,
but you don't know how to make people give a shit about you.
Right?
Like,
okay,
Greg,
I'm forcing audience to make a noise all at once.
You know what I mean?
But I can't make them remember me.
Right.
And so when I started talking about the stuff that I've learned,
you know,
I'm just an information sponge,
I just pick up shit like this,
you know?
And I started talking about,
you know,
Oh,
do you know that the diamond engagement ring was a scam on the part of the Beers
Corporation in the 30s and everyone just forgotten that we think it's tradition,
right?
That was the first one I ever did that with us.
My most sort of sit famous signature bed.
People start paying more attention,
you know,
and uh,
like,
oh my God,
I didn't realize that,
you know,
and now I'm in this weird niche,
no one else does what I do.
I do like educational investigative comedy,
right?
When you watch me,
you laugh.
And then also you learn some mind blowing shit that you're going to remember a
year from now,
you know?
And no one else is doing it.
And so the cool thing about it is when I go up there,
I'm not running in this,
you said earlier,
make your own race,
you know,
or like don't run the same race as everybody else.
Every other comic,
I'm like every other comics trying to win the hundred meter dash and maybe you
bolt's bolts in the race with them,
right?
That's Bill Burr,
whoever.
You know what I mean?
Usain bolt's trying to beat him and they're like,
fuck,
I can be pretty fast,
but I'm never gonna be number one.
You know,
I'm running a race.
I'm the only person doing this.
You know,
like I,
I'm just doing a race off to the side where like my show,
if you go to see bill Byrd,
there's more punchlines per second per sure.
For sure.
Right?
You're,
you're going to,
you're,
uh,
but I,
my show,
you're going to learn about some weird bugs and you're going to think
differently about social media.
You know,
you're going to,
you're going to come away with a new idea.
And so that's what I have to offer.
Yeah.
I've engineered it that way.
And,
and so that's what I try to tell other comics when they're just talking,
you know,
when people see my show and I'm like,
oh,
how'd you write this?
I'm like,
just figure out what you can give people that other people aren't giving them,
you know?
And like it's possible to write in a different,
in a different way.
You know?
I miss doing straight state,
like I have my straight standup hour or I just go and I tell you my stupid
observations about Shit,
you know?
Um,
and I love doing that material,
but that material is not going to get me a Netflix special,
you know,
because it's not different enough.
You know?
I see what you're saying.
So you've kind of like know you have a strategy for a little bit.
Yeah.
That's also what I want to talk about.
It's not just cynical,
but yeah.
It's not like you're being disingenuous.
This is who you are.
Yeah.
It's cool that you found a niche like that you found this little groove that you
could cut into and I'm just working on,
I have a few bits that I do that are scientific reality that people don't
believe in that or that people wouldn't imagine until you hear about it,
particularly biological stuff.
But,
but mine parasites is one that we've brought up in this podcast a fucking
thousand times.
We had some Polsky on,
Oh,
who's that?
Uh,
Robert Sapolsky from Stanford,
who's a top researcher and one of the top researchers has talked to talk a,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I talk about that a little bit in my,
in my show,
listen to his lectures on it's chlorine.
That stuff is nuts to toxoplasmosis is wild.
15 million Americans have it.
Yeah.
Probably me.
In your brain that the parasite and my understanding,
I want you,
I got this guy's research,
the research that I saw was like,
not quite definitive enough to be able to say this affects your behavior.
Right?
It's like they think maybe,
probably.
So.
I was like,
that's not enough for me,
for my show.
But like,
so,
you know,
I talk about,
but I,
you know,
what I talk about is the way that like,
the social media algorithm,
right.
Um,
is designed,
it's just like evolution,
right?
It's like,
it's just testing on you every single second year online.
And instead of trying to see whether the genes perpetuate themselves,
this test is saying,
can I get you to click a interested,
are you upset?
Are you gonna engage?
Exactly.
And the best way to get you engaged to piss you off.
And if I can get you to click,
all they do is they just reproduce that same stimuli with little changes,
just like evolution.
And by doing that,
they're able to control our behavior in a real fucking way.
And people know this,
you know,
but it really is
happening to you.
Do you,
um,
listen at Sam Harris' podcast?
Uh,
I've heard a couple times.
Yeah.
He's got a great one.
I'm pulling it up right now that I just recommend.
Yes.
If I'm going to recommend it again cause it that fucking good.
And it's a about Facebook and about how this is all set up.
It's called the trouble with Facebook.
And uh,
the guy's name is Roger Mcnamee,
n.
E.
M.
E,
but it's a episode one 52.
Yeah.
But it's really fascinating because one of the things they take into
consideration is that this company,
Facebook makes their money off of collecting your data.
The best way to collect your data is to get you to engage.
The best way to get you to engage.
It's put things in your newsfeed,
they're going to piss you off.
And it's like there's this division that's,
that's rising in this country is coincides with social media.
And it's not coincidentally,
and here's the thing,
they don't even,
the really fucked up part is the people who created these algorithms,
that is not their intent.
They're not trying to piss you off and they're not trying to create division.
All they're doing is they're like,
look,
we just want people spend as much time on the site as possible.
Algorithm,
watch what they're doing and give them more like that.
Right?
And then,
so it's happening accidentally.
Yeah.
And so then when we're all looking at Facebook on like,
look what Facebook is doing,
they're like,
what are you talking about?
Right.
It's just about,
we don't need to change anything.
You know?
Um,
we just have an algorithm rewards engagement.
Yeah.
I know,
I know that you,
I know that you had a Jack Dorsey on,
I did not hear that interview.
I just know you had him on.
I know that people are pissed off at,
you know,
like,
um,
and my own personal pissed off with them is that like they don't,
they don't take enough ownership of it,
you know,
like,
and,
and that's not just,
I don't wanna just focus on Dorsey Zuckerberg is the worst with it,
you know,
um,
that they,
uh,
these algorithms are causing these behaviors and then they're saying,
oh,
that's not,
oh well,
no,
we're not doing that.
We've just like,
we're just trying to get people to be on the site more like,
it's to connect people and so they don't change it.
Well,
what if they had no algorithm?
What if they just allowed it to exist as a,
just a,
a virtual message board?
You know,
Twitter,
no,
moderate
Twitter.
Well that's,
that's a problem itself,
right?
Cause like that's like,
okay,
a virtual message board with no moderators is like,
um,
like let,
let's just talk about fighting for instance,
right?
Like,
okay,
when you've got a UFC fight,
right,
you've got to referee,
right?
You've got a situation you've created,
you've got,
you got to a ring,
you know you've set things up.
So hey,
people are going to get hurt,
but not more than you want them to write.
A No moderators.
That's like,
Hey,
let's have a street fight with nobody watching,
right?
No one's,
there's no rules.
There's an unlimited number of people in there.
It's just people wailing on each other where people are going to get hurt.
You know?
So like I think when you are,
uh,
creating the platform,
you're creating the place where the discussion happening,
you have a responsibility for what kind of discussion happens in that place.
You know,
because you're the one who set up the ground rules.
They're trying to do that with youtube for awhile.
They were trying to say that like if you have a youtube page and your comments
are filled with antisemitic hate that you can get in trouble for that,
but you were supposed to clean up your comments and then people went,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And Youtube was like,
ah,
forget it.
Yeah.
So I backed off
on Youtube.
Right.
That's youtube.
Youtube is the one that allowed that to happen.
The con is that Youtube is the one saying that we're not going to moderate any,
could they?
How can they,
well,
I mean you,
you,
you literally need physical moderators.
Yeah,
I know.
And then that's the contradiction that they're faced with the people.
There's so many people.
Yeah.
And this is the issue with Facebook.
This is the issue with Twitter.
The real question is like,
who gets to decide what is offensive?
What is not?
I'm sure you're aware of the learn to code fiasco.
Uh,
oh.
I planned to her hand for saying learn to code.
And it was really mocking this idea that people were telling coal miners who are
losing their jobs,
you know,
hey,
there's jobs in computer programming this out,
you should learn to code.
And so people started mocking people by saying learn to code and then learn to
code.
Apparently according to Jack Dorsey and Vigia,
it got connected to a antisemetic remarks and hate remarks.
And then I decided out this level of Internet,
Internet nonsense.
Fascinating.
Because that doesn't mean anything like learn to code is not offensive.
It's like,
yeah,
well it's ridiculous to ask a 50 year old man as a coal miner to learn to code
and it doesn't have a formal education.
That is ridiculous.
But I mean the fact that you get banned for life for saying that.
So that's actually even more Riddick.
Yeah.
But then there are cases where people go and they try to create like a,
if someone,
if someone who look there are antisemites out there,
right.
They do try to come up with like ways to indicate antisemitism to each other
that other people won't detect.
You know what I mean?
Via you know,
slang.
Basically her slang.
Right?
Um,
and,
uh,
at some point someone needs to be able to say,
okay,
wait one second,
this is,
we figured out this an 87 x slang,
so we're not going to allow you to say it.
You know what I mean?
It's like shit,
like 88 or what,
isn't that a thing where it's like,
yes,
yeah.
H H how Hitler
the problem,
right?
There's the,
this is the exact problem that you're talking about.
Um,
so,
but the contrary,
the contradiction that all of these platforms have,
right,
is the early days of the Internet.
Remember the early days it was like,
uh,
people were really concerned that people would start suing websites because of
what was on the website,
right?
Like,
um,
like the pirate bay,
the big torrent site,
you know,
like you're gonna get sued because you've got DVD screeners on there.
No hold.
I said,
we're just,
this is just where people can upload the shit.
You know,
Google getting sued because they would,
you know,
direct someone or the DVDs crunch,
they searched for leaks,
DVD screener,
you know what I mean?
And so that was a big concern in the early days of the Internet,
right?
And so we established this precedent that like,
no,
these sites don't have responsibility for that right there.
Just how people are connecting to things.
They're not people doing the bad shit,
right?
You go over the people doing the batch shit,
not the people who made it possible to find the bad shit.
Right now though,
we're in such a place where,
so all these businesses built themselves on the idea of youtube,
right?
We don't make anything right.
Youtube,
we just give you a place to upload your videos,
right?
So at first that's fine.
All right.
Just take down the antisemitic,
you know,
white supremacy videos,
right?
Whatever.
Right?
But now there's so,
so many of them.
Right?
And also,
not only that,
Youtube's algorithm is directing people towards them,
and Youtube is selling ads against them and making money at them.
Right?
Um,
and at the same time,
like,
you know,
these,
these videos exist,
right?
Um,
uh,
and,
at the same time,
there's still trying to say,
well,
we had no responsibility for that happened.
[inaudible],
you guys built a system where any kind of content is allowed and you are,
you've also got the sentence and that's directing people to that content and you
build a system that's making money off of that content.
Think you guys have a little bit of responsibility.
Now.
I agree that the question of who polices it or whatever,
that's an extremely complicated conversation.
But like that's what I'm just saying about these companies trying to have it
both ways.
They're trying to say we have no responsibility for what's on the platform,
but also we've allowed this kind of content to go up,
you know,
don't know if you to profits on antisemetic videos.
I don't know.
I talk about in my show of a demonetizing aspect of youtube that affects people
whenever anything's even remotely controversial,
controversial.
They've started,
they've started doing that.
Um,
up until like,
there was a case,
I talk about it in my show,
um,
uh,
like a year,
year or two ago where they were like running under Armour brand a underarmour
ads on like white supremacy,
youtube videos,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
And that that was like,
and their algorithm was causing this,
what's causing that to happen?
Right?
And these are videos getting a hundred thousands of hits and it was like major
brands and those brands found out.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
And then the title of these video,
like we'll kind of,
we'll get on it.
They say obvious antisemitic thing.
These were,
these were obvious enough that anybody would be pissed off about him.
Yeah.
Um,
and uh,
so that's where the demonetization thing came from,
right?
Because they're like,
oh shit,
now the people who actually pay us,
the advertisers are pissed off,
right?
Yeah.
So,
okay,
let's put a bandaid on the problem and let's do monetize videos.
Right?
Here's the problem.
Now they're doing that.
They're just doing that algorithmically,
right?
They're choosing which videos to demonetize algorithmically.
So sometimes they demonetize stuff that they shouldn't.
That's definitely happened a ton and a lot of shit is still getting through the
cracks,
you know?
And again,
they're saying,
okay,
we did what we did,
what we had to know.
You guys didn't solve the fucking problem because now people are pissed off
again.
Right.
So that is the vine that these companies rent there based on this premise of we
don't moderate,
moderate anything.
But when you do that,
a lot of shit comes in and now you're in the position where,
sorry,
it's still your house.
The Shit's happened in your house.
You had through the House party dude.
Like stuff like the base got broken.
It's your fault.
At the end of the day you have to take some responsibility for it.
And then,
well how am I supposed to police do a hundred kids?
I don't know.
You're the one who threw the party.
That's a good analogy because it sits right.
The scale.
That's the problem.
It's probably more like 200,000 kids in a house.
Totally.
Cause it's,
there's,
it's unmanageable.
Yeah.
When you think about how many different people are on youtube and how many
different countries are uploading videos and you know,
some of them are isis beheading videos.
Those,
those,
like there's a bunch of cartel videos that people have sent me to on Youtube and
they stay up for a little while.
Yeah.
You know,
you get to watch some horrible shit for a little while before they catch on.
Or like I talk about these
videos,
uh,
in my show where like the,
the weird nonsense kids videos on youtube where it's like people in Spiderman
costumes doing like weird community theater.
You know what I mean?
In like Spiderman,
Elsa videos or like so strange.
There's so many,
if you look at kids youtube,
it's still so full of it.
Like they've tried to stamp it out.
There's still tons of it.
And these videos,
like literally I show a video,
which is just total nonsense,
like looks like it was made by a computer.
It's just weird garbage doesn't look wrong until you actually watch it closely.
And then you're like,
this video is saying we are nonsense.
The video has 600 million views,
right?
And it's just garbage.
Right?
And I have literally spent my whole life trying to make good internet content,
make condoms the funny entertaining that people like and I can't get close to
that number to hits.
And it's because the algorithm is controlling what people are watching,
right?
So penny towards people towards nonsense.
Well,
so that people are watching this because it has Elsa or Spiderman or they're
watching this,
they're watching it because they're a five year old and the video was given to
them up next by youtube and the video's title and key words and like content has
managed to hack the algorithm,
find the weird edge case in the algorithm that put it in front of those kids
over and over it.
You've seen the ones where they break down those videos where it's weird like
there's always like a baby and alcohol.
Yep.
And someone always gets hurt from a broken bottle like you over and over and
over again.
These things happen.
They do that because it's sort of like they've found that people that make those
videos have found how to hack the out because algorithms are not that smart.
Right?
They're not brilliant things.
They're just like a little bit of code.
It's just like in a video game you don't have,
when you're playing a video game and you like figure out,
you're like,
oh,
the video game thinks that when x happens.
I'm trying to do why,
but now that I figured that out,
I can exploit that.
Right,
right.
I can figure out how to freeze that guy in place or,
or just like when you're a kid and you could figure how to scroll.
The enemy's off the screen in nes games go left then.
Right.
Oh,
they disappear.
You know,
you'd figure out how to,
how to hack the algorithm.
That's what the people who make these videos have done with the algorithm as
well.
They figured out a little whole
in a way that works and they forgot it.
Oh,
if we just do this,
the video gets shown again and again and again.
And here's the thing,
70% of all videos watched on youtube are being served by the algorithm.
70% people are watching a billion hours of youtube a day.
So,
so people are not choosing what we're watching the algorithms choosing and the
people that the video is,
the algorithm is showing us are the ones that people are like hacking.
You know,
I like these weird fucked up video,
my shoulder,
this algorithm.
Yeah,
that is really interesting.
And it's also interesting that these companies have figured this thing out.
Like A,
I don't know if you ever get,
you see,
um,
like whenever I post something,
they're always be like if I post something on Instagram,
there'll be look within the first,
second or two,
four or five of these accounts that like a,
are you just going to pretend
I don't have a giant booty?
And you're like,
what is this?
And you go to it and it's some weird sneaky sort of computer generated thing
where it'll say it on with a bunch of different accounts.
The exact same thing with emojis and then you go to it and it's some ripped off
pictures of some girl with a big ass,
right?
Yeah.
And then somehow or another,
the trying to get you,
but they've capitalized on this comment section to find people that have posts
that get a lot of comments and you get a lot of views and then they go right to
it.
And then that's how they tap into it.
And that's my point of,
of how this works,
right?
So Instagram set up a set up a comment system.
These people have figured out how to hack the comment system to get their
bullshit spam on the top within seconds.
I mean it's so fast they couldn't possibly have written it yet.
Like it has to be a program and that's,
and that's Instagram's fault for allowing that to happen at the end of the day.
You know what I mean?
Like that's Instagram's problem to solve.
You know?
And that's the problem.
All of these platforms have that.
The Prime Youtube has as a problem Twitter has.
And so whenever they say,
oh no,
it's just a couple of bad apples,
it's like you guys threw the party,
you guys figured out how to fix it.
Right?
Shitty orchardson yeah.
I mean youtube is amazing in that,
you know,
you really can be entertained with things like for someone who's into obscure
things in particular,
it's one of the best resources ever.
I a career off of Youtube.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
but it's also like if you want to watch old things,
you want to watch interesting things.
I mean,
you can find almost everything on youtube,
including things that are not true.
Let's,
this is like whether cracking down on certain things like earth videos,
it's a library of Alexandria man.
Like I remember there used to be like in New York,
uh,
I never actually went and did this,
but there was like a museum that had like lots of old archival TV.
You know,
you could go back,
you could watch the first episode of Johnny Carson or whatever.
You know what I mean?
I was like,
oh,
that's so cool right now.
You don't need to go to that library.
You can just,
it's literally on Youtube.
The first episode of Johnny Carson ever is on Youtube was the guest.
Uh,
I don't remember.
Um,
I don't think I'm exaggerating.
I have seen it on the web.
I saw like his very first appearance.
Sure.
It's up there,
or at least the early,
you know,
cause maybe the early ones weren't taped,
but it was like super,
super early.
It's got like black hair,
you know?
Wow.
Um,
and so like,
you know,
every episode of the daily show ever is on the Internet,
and so,
uh,
and you know,
say you like,
uh,
you know,
name a Sonos,
Sonos,
I go send,
I just go watch a,
you know,
name an old jazz musician.
You can,
won't go watch him play live.
You know what I mean?
We watched the loneliest monk closeups of his hands,
you know what I mean?
That's incredible.
And so like,
and I still hope in my heart of hearts that like that is at the end of the day,
Youtube is serving a good purpose because we still have access to all that
information.
You know,
my videos do pretty well on youtube.
My videos aren't,
aren't white supremacist,
you know,
Spiderman nonsense,
they're good,
you know,
so hopefully they're doing some good in the world.
But at the,
you know,
I as I hope in my heart of hearts that like,
this is still a positive force for humanity.
I think it's a positive for us.
But overall,
the problem that we're talking about,
whether it's problem with youtube or the problem with the Facebook algorithm,
any of these things,
it's people that suck.
That's the problem.
Yeah,
it's not,
it's not people that are putting up videos of Thelonious monk.
It's not,
you know,
someone making something educational on vitamins or something like that.
It's bullshit.
The bullshit,
the problem,
the problem is people exploiting the system and using that system to stick
nonsense or,
or bad things up there,
but if you're the company that's allowing that bullshit to happen and you make
money off of it,
you know it's an issue,
but it's also,
it's like part of it is a really interesting to me,
like part,
I don't like the fact that it's all this.
I don't like the fact that there's some ungodly number of kids.
I think the fucking world is flat because they watched a youtube video and there
was no one who is there while the guy was making the youtube video to go stop.
That's not true.
I'll show you how.
This is how you do it.
There you go.
There's the data.
Okay,
next.
Keep going.
Stop.
That's not true either.
You don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
Of course it works like that.
This is why it works like that.
And this is what it means.
Did you see our video on the moon landing?
No.
Oh,
this is one of my favorite videos.
Did.
So,
uh,
you know,
it's about how the moon land,
th the thesis is the moon landing could not have been faked.
It would have been harder to fake the moon landing then it would have been to
actually go to the moon because the technology to fake it did not exist when we
talked to a,
uh,
forensic film guy.
Right?
And he was like,
spins.
He's got like a,
he's got a fucking Oscar for,
um,
you know,
analyzing old films.
Right?
And he walked us through it.
He's like,
look,
the shadows are parallel.
Right?
They're not diverging.
You know,
a close light
source.
The shadows would,
would diverge.
Right?
Um,
so
wait a minute.
You know that that's like,
one of the big arguments for the moon hoax is that the shadows intersect.
The shadows indicate multiple light sources.
Uh,
well that is because,
uh,
when,
but that's one of the main arguments.
That is a,
I believe that's reflected light.
Okay.
I'm getting past my memory of the segment,
but used to be a full on moon hoaxer I fully believed we never went to the,
I shouldn't have brought this up.
Watch the documentary that was on Fox TV while I was on news was like 1995 or
something like that.
I was fucking convince these radios,
one of my favorite sitcoms ever by the way.
That is a unacknowledged classic.
Uh,
I have watched the whole series like three times.
Um,
that show is so,
I'm sorry,
just go ahead and set this up.
Anyway.
Um,
back then Fox News actually aired a full one hour show calling co called
conspiracy theory.
Did we land on the moon?
And it had me fully convinced there was all this shit that they showed,
like the same background being used in multiple moon missions that were supposed
to be on completely different parts of the moon.
Like how is this possible?
It's supposed to be like nowhere near each other,
but they have the same background and that is a,
it looks like the astronauts are on wires and it looks like the light sources
are there,
multiple light sources and the shadows are intersecting.
And you know,
all the fucking astronauts,
when they came back,
they did this,
uh,
Apollo 11 post flight,
a press conference,
and it looked like they're completely full of shit.
I was all in dude,
all in,
all in and now you're all out.
No,
I realized,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking.
That's one of the,
we all need to be a problem with being all in with air,
with anything.
But we also found that they did fake some things for publicity purposes.
Photographs that were used that were,
uh,
photographs from tests that they did inside a warehouse with all safety
equipment and then they blacked out all the safety equipment in the background.
And s pawn those photos off as spacewalk photos.
But I think that's overzealous publicists.
It doesn't mean no one went to space.
It's like making leaps.
Is it public?
Well,
what's the simplest explanation?
If you did fake some footage,
well,
it's probably a bunch of simple explanations,
but overzealous publicists,
people wanted to show people video that they didn't have video of.
Maybe the,
the photos didn't come out so well,
so they fake some of them.
Well,
let me let,
let the,
the thing about the shadows diverging,
my memory of this is,
we don't talk about that.
When people say they see the shadows diverge,
right?
If you actually go outside on a sunny day,
when you have a single point of light like that with light reflecting,
you will see two shadows of yourself going in different,
there's one dominant shadow and then there's a,
there's a secondary one,
right?
But if the shadow,
if the sun is actually far away,
right?
For the main shadow,
you will see the same shadows be parallel,
right?
If you had a close light source,
like on a film,
on a film set,
you see the shadows diverge,
right?
So at this film,
Forensic Guy,
come on and tell us,
look,
if you wanted to get perfectly straight light like that,
you would need lasers.
You would,
and you would also,
but you'd also need multicolored lasers because at the time all that existed
were red lasers.
Right.
They had not existed.
They're not an invented anything other than red lasers.
Right.
So NASA would have had to have multi,
multi decade advanced laser light technology in order to fake this.
Another part of it is that they just hard Kubrick,
he'd figured out,
I mean,
no,
I mean this is,
this is what we demonstrated in our segment.
You know,
another part of it is people forget the moon broadcast.
The moon landing broadcast was something like a six hour live broadcast with no
cuts,
you know,
and at the time,
that was something you could do with TV,
but you literally couldn't do it with film.
Right.
There was no way to record film as,
sorry,
there's no way to record TV at the time you had live TV and you had recorded
film.
Right.
So if they were going to record it in advance,
right.
And then play it back,
they would have needed a six hour long reel of tape.
There's no commercials.
And they're,
uh,
I don't believe so.
Um,
and so,
uh,
they would have had to say,
so we should probably know if there was commercials cause that's a fair point.
But you know,
you would have needed like an enormous film canister that also didn't exist.
It was going to have an enormous film canister.
It'd be those fucking hoaxers at NASA.
Well done.
And well part of the premise of the,
part of the premise of the,
we didn't go to the moon argument is that we didn't have the technology to go to
the moon.
So they fixed it.
Right,
right.
But it's like,
okay,
well if you have to postulate that they had decades ahead of its time filmmaking
technology,
why can't you accept that they just went to the fucking moon,
you know?
So the,
at the end when you go through all the things that would have to happen,
right,
in order to make it,
have you really go through it and look at what
is the simplest explanation.
The simplest explanation is that we went to the moon because it would have been
fucking easier.
I don't know if it would have been easier.
If it was impossible to go to the moon,
it would be insanely difficult to fake,
no doubt.
But if you had an incredible budget and if you had someone who really had the
very top of the food chain knowledge in terms of special effects,
what Kubrick did in 2001 one one was,
when was that?
When did 2001 come out and want to sell at 71 or some shit like that?
When does that come out?
Uh,
see,
yeah,
look it up.
I think it was earlier than that.
Maybe 68 68 okay,
so we're talking about before the moon landings,
Cooper cats and pretty astonishing special effects in 2001 yeah,
but the,
the,
I mean,
the argument is that like even given,
again,
this is like film maker sang this,
given the film technology of the time,
the specific features that we see in the moon footage are not favorable.
You know,
another part of it is,
for instance,
the slow jumping,
right?
The slow boom,
boom.
You know,
you're on the moon,
right?
The big argument that the moon true Thurs make is that it was regular speed
footage and it was slowed down.
Right,
right.
And there's this dude on,
I can't read the name of it.
Um,
but if you search or is there a filmmaker on youtube,
right.
And he just breaks down.
Why like the ability to overcrank and like shooting slow mo like that.
Like didn't,
that wasn't how film cameras worked at the time,
you know.
Um,
uh,
and so couldn't air things in slow mo back then.
Um,
look you're good at,
you're good at asking questions cause you asked me to get into details that I
don't have a up top of my head,
but that's the,
that's the argument that,
that the dude makes.
Um,
it's not one of the arguments that we make specifically on our show because we
only had six minutes,
so we did the best ones.
It's always an interesting argument when you're talking about the moon landing.
I also know about how much your audience do you think is going to be fucking
furious at me for talking about this because they believe the moon landing was
faked.
It like 15% I was exactly going to be my guest.
It's always a number,
man.
There's a number of years.
I think that vaccines cause autism.
Dr Peter Hotez on here who is an expert in tropical diseases and autism safety
and he's explaining that they've isolated five environmental factors that
contribute to autism.
When it's in the child's womb,
they've isolated genes.
They think they've got an understanding of what's causing this or how it's how
it,
at least it's happening,
but it's happening in the womb.
They don't think there's any connection to vaccines and autism.
They think there's people who have autism who get vaccinated in their autism
symptoms show up,
but they were probably going to have those symptoms anyway.
And there's a human correlation that they make.
It doesn't mean that some people don't get adversely affected by vaccines
because people have very strange reactions to all sorts of things.
Cause we very biologically,
it doesn't mean that vaccines are giving people autism.
And when you say that people go fucking ballistic,
the comments fill with hate and Zionist shill and this and that.
It's wild.
I get that shit a lot.
But,
but what we're doing here,
you and I
are,
even if we disagree,
this is what I think is one of the most important things of our time,
is the ability to have reasonable conversations.
I agree.
And I try to tell people,
um,
when they disagree with me,
because when people come in and meet with a lot of heat on the Internet,
you know,
a lot of times I don't have time to get into it,
but I do like to occasionally,
you know,
reply and say,
someone like,
Oh,
you're so full of shit.
Like you lied about this and that,
blah,
blah.
You know,
and I tried to get new essay say,
and I,
and I say,
hey,
thanks for watching the show.
You know,
um,
I don't feel that we lied.
This is where evidence says,
you know,
what,
what do you think?
You know?
And I try to take their temperature down,
you know,
and I don't match their anger is the most important part.
I'm like much nicer than their anger demands,
you know?
And that usually cools them off right away.
And then we have a conversation,
you know,
and a lot of the time when I do that,
uh,
they leave going,
okay,
you know what,
we,
we don't disagree that much,
you know,
or,
or okay,
thanks for talking to me,
you know.
Um,
but the most important thing I say to them is,
uh,
even if I don't turn them around on whatever the issue was,
um,
I say okay.
They say I'm never going to watch your show again cause you lied about this,
you know,
cause I disagree with it but you're wrong about this.
I'm never watching Shogun.
And I say,
okay,
why would you never watch the show again?
Just because you disagree with me about one thing.
Like I watched tons of stuff with people I don't disagree,
you know,
like don't really mean that.
They just want you to feel bad.
Yeah,
exactly.
yeah,
absolutely.
Followed five,
never watching you again followed like,
does anybody think it's a good idea to only consume shit that you already agree
with?
I think it's better to challenge yourself and to watch things that you,
that you don't agree with all the time.
You Watch Fox News at least one hour every week.
Do you really watch it an hour and just go,
what the fuck?
But it's happening.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of,
you know,
they're like,
I want to know what white people really up to.
They're scared all the time when they're around me.
They lie.
I need to know.
I'll have to be,
I would have to get high with Laura Ingram,
see how she's getting in trouble for laughing at Nipsey a hustles funeral.
That was very bizarre.
Strange.
It's very strange to be,
they're laughing to be so dialed in to that.
Look,
I understand when you're in,
when you're one of those hosts,
right?
You have a message,
you're dialed into it.
You got to say that message every single day.
Every single time you're like,
you're a monomaniacal about it.
You know what I mean?
But to do that about,
about someone's death specifically bizarre,
you know?
And that sort of gives you sometimes I think that TV shows or like a curse,
you know,
um,
like I feel for anybody who has to be on TV every day,
their life narrows down to that Little Camera Lens and they can't have a thought
outside of it.
You know what I mean?
So all those paper,
Tucker,
Tucker Carlson,
Rachel Maddow,
Laura Ingram,
you know what I mean?
Like they like chambers.
Yeah.
Apart from me disagreeing with,
you know,
some of them on various things.
I disagree with all folks on occasion.
Um,
like to live your life right in that Lens,
saying the same thing every night.
It must really impoverish your point of view in a,
in a way that's really a bummer.
And me seeing her do that,
it's like,
yeah,
that's a great perspective.
Impoverished in your point of view.
I think you're onto that.
Well,
thank you.
I,
I mean,
that's when I saw,
when I saw that clip of her,
I was like,
I can't,
I can't believe you know,
but it,
it,
it's t being on TV makes you crazy person
probably does man with them.
With Laura Ingram.
It was also,
they had just played a clip of one of Nipsey hussle is videos for one of his
songs that was called Fuck Donald Trump.
Yeah.
And they were mocking the song and laughing and I'm like,
look,
it's not about the guys aren't the guy's dead.
He was murdered in Los Angeles and obviously you look at all the hundreds of
thousands of people that are mourning him in the streets.
They loved him.
Yeah.
Why did they love him?
Maybe look at that.
Maybe because he was giving back to the community.
Maybe it's because the guy became successful and still wanted to be in the
community and help people out because he was a positive influence on a lot of
young people.
Yeah.
So he had a song called Fuck Donald Trump,
whatever.
And then we're,
and you know,
the worst thing I think,
what's that on that song?
But it's not his why g what is the one ice cubes got a dope song about the
president.
He might,
it might be like,
kill the arrest,
the president.
It might be called the rest of the president.
Pretty fucking good.
You know,
the,
the worst thing that I think is his new ice cubes,
new shit.
Uh,
the,
the worst thing I think that people say is like,
um,
uh,
the,
the perspective that she had was okay,
because he doesn't like Donald Trump.
He's not worthy of respect right here.
I'm not,
I'm not going to be sad he's dead because he said something mean about Donald
Trump.
Right?
Dad is such a malignant version of the way that so many people feel like the
most frustrating thing people say to me is,
um,
you know,
on,
on our comp,
no comments page on youtube page.
This guy's a liberal.
This guy's a Democrat,
so I'm not going to listen to them.
I'm like,
okay,
well,
first of all,
we criticize Democrats and liberals all the time on the show.
You know,
so those people are like dual responsibility.
They're like,
does it Adam?
Conover realize he's criticizing a Democrat priority.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I all the time,
you know,
like we,
uh,
are,
we do not do a political show.
You know,
look,
I live in Los Angeles,
right?
I went to college.
I didn't vote for Donald Trump.
You know what I mean?
Um,
uh,
like most people who didn't.
All right,
so I'm going to,
I'm going to fess up to that.
Right.
Why does that mean that you would never listen to anything I ever had to say or
that you would treat me with disrespect,
right.
Trying to make you feel bad,
bro.
Yeah.
Talking about it right now.
So they win.
Uh,
all fair enough.
Fair enough.
Yeah.
Okay.
We can move off of it,
but you know,
that I,
that idea of someone who disagrees with me is like not a person who I'm going to
listen to anymore.
What a,
what a bummer.
Yeah.
It wasn't the people from all,
all perspectives and backgrounds.
That's my goal.
Even more insidious.
What they're doing is they're trying to say,
this whole life that was just lost is this one clip that says fuck the fuck
Donald Trump.
That's so stupid.
He's obviously a lot of things like that's quote mining.
You're taking a little tiny piece of some things that he did out of context and
you putting it on your show and then you're mocking his death.
And it's unfortunate.
But again,
I think it's these echo chambers.
He's,
people think it's okay to do that.
They know that the other people that are like them,
we're going to react the same way.
Like what the guy had a song called Fuck Donald Trump.
I mean,
hey fuck,
kill her.
And then they just get,
they all just repeat that and they think that's like the people that were
shocked that Trump won.
They couldn't believe anybody would vote for Trump because everybody around you
would not see it.
You get stuck in these echo chambers.
You don't understand how other people outside see it.
And I think that's what's happening.
You know,
with this,
it's just a hundred percent sad.
It's a guy's fucking dead guy was murdered.
Yeah,
we did a,
um,
you know,
we did a segment on,
on guns,
right?
We didn't episode on guns.
And I always thought that I said at the beginning of our show,
we'd never do an episode on guns because it's too divisive.
And as soon as we did the topic,
people,
everyone had fold their arms.
And these are,
you can do an episode on guns.
Well,
you better say what I want you to say,
or I'm changing the channel.
Right?
And we,
uh,
but we been doing the show for four years.
I was like,
I think we can finally do it.
And here's the thing,
everybody is wrong about guns.
That's the premise of our show.
Everyone's wrong about everything.
You know,
if you think you know about something,
you probably don't,
and anything,
any topic that I do,
I'm going to tell you something you don't know.
Right.
And so we specifically did an episode that's about,
you know,
we,
we had a,
you know,
a gun gun rights advocate at gun control advocate.
I'm talking to both of them.
And they're both making mistakes,
right.
Um,
about it.
and,
uh,
that was the point.
Was that like,
the thing that liberals not,
I don't want to say liberals,
the thing that gun control advocates,
right often fail to do is they failed to take seriously that the gun rights
advocates are like real people who live in the same country as them,
who they need to deal with as humans.
Right?
Like the NRA is,
has a lot of,
I'm not going to defend the NRA for a second.
Right?
I think the NRA is a very extreme organization that is not productive,
you know.
Um,
but like the average gun con,
the average gun owner in your community,
right,
is a real person you have to deal with.
Right?
And if you're just in your echo chamber and you're not taking that person
seriously,
then you're not gonna make any progress.
Right.
Um,
and so you need to,
you know,
uh,
gun control advocates are,
and just as much need of correction,
you know,
and just as much need of,
of checking themselves and,
you know,
examining their own biases and,
getting closer to the truth as,
uh,
as gun rights advocates.
Yeah.
Particularly if you want to ever resolve it or come to any sort of an agreement,
you can't treat the other people like they're stupid.
Like you fucking morons don't get it.
Okay,
well that's not helping anybody.
And that the issue with people that also get angry at people who voted for
Trump,
they want to say they're all stupid.
Okay.
You want to say that?
Half the country stupid.
That's not a good idea.
That's not smart.
Yeah.
I want to say the reason
I said I,
I went to college,
I didn't vote for Donald Trump.
Not because a lot of college,
a lot of people went to college,
did vote for Donald Trump.
The trend is that they is,
that they didn't vote for him,
you know,
so I was trying to say I'm in a different demographic,
but I don't want people to think of what I was replying.
I believe so.
Yeah.
Um,
it's,
I mean that's sort of how it breaks down.
Like people,
you know,
people with bas or higher tend to,
tend to vote for.
So I'm just like giving
a nod to the demographics here.
This is how it breaks down.
Right.
Um,
I've got to wrap this up as a man.
It was a lot of fun.
Absolutely o'clock.
Can you believe it?
Holy Shit.
Three oh five for a while.
Thank you.
Uh,
Oh,
you got the call.
I was wondering what time it was.
Well,
hey,
this has been a real,
I really appreciate the,
we got deep on some shit.
It was fun,
man.
Thanks.
Yeah,
thanks.
I appreciate it.
And tell everybody when you show is when they can watch it.
Uh,
Adam ruins everything.
Sounds true.
TV.
We got episodes on Netflix.
A new episodes are coming out probably around August.
Don't have an exact date yet,
but we're having our,
our next run of eight or not.
Then you can do this,
you know,
uh,
hopefully stuff and check out my new podcast.
Factually a no,
no.
So sorry.
Hopefully pretty soon we will.
We'll know whether we're going to keep doing it.
Word between.
We're waiting for a pickup,
right?
He's doing it.
Yeah.
I love doing the show.
Look,
I'm going to be doing what I do for the rest of my life no matter where I'm
doing it,
so,
oh,
that's a good way to look at it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Awesome.
Adam,
thank you.
Thank you so much,
man.
Thanks for being here.
Great.